guys thank you so much for buying the
trash taste tour tickets we've sold out
in so many venues so much so that we're
actually adding an extra show an extra
show in los angeles on the 23rd of
september the first la show we had sold
out pretty much right away so we wanted
to add an extra day and because it's
going to be our first show of the tour
it's going to be a little tester show so
if you want to see an early version of
the show then go to trashtaster.com that
is trashtaster.com
so come see us live get your tickets
smash that link yeah what do you think
is the worst
us beer that you guys export a lot it's
all [ __ ] i mean it's like if you have
bud light you have natty light bud
guys yeah yeah that sucks
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste i'm your host for today
garnet once again are joining me are the
boys as usual and again we have another
very special guest today do you want to
introduce yourself to our audience just
in case there is someone who doesn't
know
who you are what you do out there i'm
sure there's a lot i'm ludwig and i
stream sometimes sometimes yeah
sometimes just sometimes okay i mean i
got the every six hours i got the
youtube bag it's like once a week these
days
one foot out the door halfway to
retirement oh yeah yeah you're just
living the life man once you you get
like i feel like the end goal of every
streamer is just like to get signed up
and just like live the cushy like comfy
life and that's you're [ __ ] living
the dream man that well that was it for
a long time i was like okay just get
really really big and then like mixer
will give you a big offer and then you
just stay on twitch and you get paid a
[ __ ] ton of money to do what you were
doing anyway yeah
yeah yeah it's the dream you're like 30
million dollars for eight months of work
uh and so that was always the dream but
that dream's kind of dying
what do you mean why they stopped
handing out big juicy fat contracts oh
like every other week i'll hit up
youtube i'll be like hey sign this
person like a streamer friend of mine
who i think is really good yeah and then
be like you know we spent all our budget
and i'm like on one and then
and then uh and then twitch is handing
out like the worst deals of all time
really yeah yeah have you heard about it
i haven't heard about this what are
those they're so they're just like
they used to offer deals but they've
realized that even if people leave who
are big streamers they still have a
monopoly it's like 70 percent like right
of the whole market so like
we don't need to pay anyone so they just
don't right and no one will leave unless
they get paid by youtube and youtube's
pockets only go so deep for this kind of
sounds like the deal with like youtubers
where you know i remember like a lot of
youtubers went through like a massive
phase and they're still going through a
phase where you know they [ __ ] hated
the platform especially when like the
content system get like got implemented
yeah and then everyone wanted to leave
youtube to go to a different platform
but then like there is no other there is
no other platform so they just gotta
like [ __ ] suck it up and deal with it
the best case like out of that is you
end up looking like the republicans who
go to gab or truth social media there's
like eight of them and donald trump all
hanging out
you don't want to be that guy no
so you know you just gotta stick with
the website even if it sucks yeah i
remember back in the day uh there used
to be like other websites that try to
compete like i remember i don't know if
you were around when every like reviewer
movie reviewer like moved to blip to
like try to like just play
this is like back in like the that guy
with the glasses era where
like nobody could post like reviews on
youtube so everyone was everyone moved
to this new
up-and-coming website called blip and
well the fact that they haven't heard of
it just says it says all the story that
needs to be said about what happened
with that website um but it just seems
like any time there's a different site
that tries to compete
with like the [ __ ] big players now it
just never works out like okay okay are
you allowed to say now that you've been
streaming on youtube for a while do you
think it has an opportunity to compete
with blip in the future with blip i'm
sorry
uh with twitch as a like a live streamer
yeah yeah yeah i think for the next five
years twitch will probably remain the
top dog but i do think twitch is
mismanaged so badly at the top like the
only way to grow on twitch and everyone
internally knows is to grow on another
website and then go to twitch yeah right
yeah and i think there's a lot of
pressure for them to be profitable and
they've done like or announced that they
might like slash pay like 30 for
creators uh or they might make people
like run ads and so they've done a lot
of things that are unfavorable but it's
because amazon's like hey you've been
losing hundreds of millions for five
years now could you please stop and
eventually i think what will break the
camel's back is if they get rid of
twitch prime right well because like
another thing that i've realized
recently about twitch is that it's i i
feel like twitch like in my mind was way
more of a mature platform
uh than i thought it was because i think
what made me realize this recently was
the recent meta of just you know
streaming copyrighted shows right and
there was just nothing that was done
about that and you look at something
like youtube i mean you lasted like what
24 hours or something before you had
your first yeah on youtube or something
like that dude i got knocked off so many
times for like listening to songs like
even if i listen to like the naruto like
[Applause]
and i'm playing like a blitz game of
chess and i'm like let's go boys
it'll just be like like oop and then
it'll take me down um
and so
it's it's crazy what you can get away
with on twitch yeah and i think a lot of
streamers would struggle even with like
the daily like hey let's react to videos
thing yeah yeah and they would just get
burned yeah i'm not really a fan of that
anyway i don't really like reacting to
videos
i don't know why it's tight
watch youtube offline why are you gonna
i don't know well i i agree with you
i think
like 95 of the time the thing that i
like doing is like watching
what i do these days i i have my mods i
pay them all and i'm like hey get me a
list of like the coolest food from every
country it'll be like a like a minute
clip of all that and i'll watch them all
on stream and so it's like a compilation
of all of those with the overarching
idea of like which place is the coolest
food yeah i think you did one with like
youtubers from different countries yeah
yeah exactly and so that i do that a lot
uh but i do i get uncomfortable when i'm
just sitting there even watching like a
kurz gazette video yeah they've given me
permission to watch it but sometimes i'm
sitting there and it's almost like i
feel like i'm high and i'm like i
haven't said anything in a while
or do they know that i haven't said
anything
and then i'll watch xqc like react to
like
watch him he reacts to movie recaps yeah
i've seen him oh
you've seen this
it's a text-to-speech voice that is like
someone wrote and it'll be like a movie
like the martian it'll be like matt
damon goes to space and he has to live
there for 60 days and it's the entire
movie for 10 minutes and he just watches
it and he won't say a word and i'm like
man he's the goat
that is like a new level of just like
gaming the system yeah like what's next
just like reading like entire hollywood
scripts like text to speeches
just the b-movie text-to-speech
sitting there reacting laughing
as if you could actually see it in your
mind
it's like oh rayleigh yeah
so like is it like because i've talked
to a lot of twitch streamers they
constantly talk about like the meta of
like whatever's going on in twitch how
is that set is there just like a few
people at the top just like
figuring out something new and then
everyone just kind of copies that it's
just like toilet paper you know where
like when uh when everyone was buying
toilet paper everyone's just freaking
out what they think is the matter yeah
it's just such [ __ ] everyone's just
like this is the meta and you're like
why just because one person did it yeah
yeah you're right it's just it feels
like a fire sale everyone's the same
thing on youtube though you get it is it
really i don't know youtube's i don't
know i think i think well i think in the
for a lot of trends that are like a lot
easier to do i guess and you know
obviously like if mr beast starts doing
something then not everyone's going to
jump on to that because there's a high
bar of entry but if it's something like
you know like you know any of the
[ __ ] stupid youtube challenges right
it was also the same thing i guess but
like i feel like on youtube at least
there is like tangible numbers you can
be like this is the result like if you
take a hot knife and cut something
you'll get 10 million views that's
guaranteed but sometimes on twitch i
feel like it's just like oh this big guy
did it and there's no like numbers
saying this improved or made it any
better it's just like just jump on it i
think it's usually related to something
timely so like our forward slash place
is a great example that could have only
happened in that window yeah i'd say
that's that's valid among us when it
came out is because it was hot yeah and
like usually the metas are things that
are happening because like either
there's an innovation like oh i can
stream in a hot tub in a bikini
innovation
that's innovative
that's america
going forward the car the plane amaranth
in that order
and so that's like usually what dictates
it but you're right like sometimes
there's lulls and like down times yeah
and then like xqc will play like fall
guys and it's like is fall guys back now
and it's like well yeah and you can kind
of force the meta yeah i just feel like
that like one time there was a thing
where it was like the meta was putting
the v2 attack yeah for like no reason
yeah that's it but that's like a full
meter it's like yeah it's useless
yeah it's not like chess which was like
a real like you know
it's just like falling off
i mean it's kind of coming back as
candidates i'm trying to make it a
metadata again a meta again i'm trying
to bring it back
yeah you're one of the meta setters
right yeah i have the power i think i
can because i have this idea of chess
but you see the eval bar while you play
right and you've all done chess right
yeah oh was in the players see the event
yes while you're playing you see the
eval bar which if you don't know it just
there's like a bar and it's usually
split 50 white 50 black when you start
and the better you play like the more in
one favor it is yeah and you know when
you're playing in a tournament you're
like am i doing bad am i winning like
what the [ __ ] is going on
but if you could see a bar that's like
you are doing great you'd be like cool
and i think you play better because of
it
i don't think i would though i don't
know like this is literally the
equivalent of having a friend behind you
yeah yeah yeah yeah
magnus carlson
literally just yeah
like i remember like i remember when i
when i first tried streaming chess
i thought okay i'm pretty i'm okay at
chess right yeah and then i was
trying to stream for the first time with
while reading twitch chat and like my
performance just dipped by about 20 i
swear to god because if there's a game
that like backseat gaming puts you off
of it's chess yeah yeah because like you
constantly doubt yourself with every
every single move so
i don't know if that would help or
enhance i guess not because twitch
shit's all dumb dumbasses the eval bar
is god
you know you eval is a literal algorithm
yeah that like works in your favor right
but i i okay i feel like it would it
would snowball it way more right because
if you're ahead you'll get like way more
confident but if you're like even like
five percent behind i feel like that rip
i feel like okay remake guys
i'm tilted i'm already tilted you know
i think it'd be interesting like like
for example if it says like mate in 13
it's like okay now i spend more time
looking to find something if you don't
find it and i think it'd make you play
better and then you run the clock and
you lose yeah yeah maybe either way
i'll bring the meda back i will implore
you all to jump back into the chess meta
you've always
i got a dm from iron mouse before this
and she's like be mean to connor and i
was like all right what the [ __ ] all
right
it's not hard yeah everyone's mean to me
just a good punching bag
i like to play more like because like
one thing that's awesome about you know
chess.com is that the ui is just so
clean but i remember like playing connor
with like a real board
and that was just like way more
challenging than like
yeah it's so hard to see things
yeah
i don't understand like i think uh it's
a thing when they teach young people
they never have them play online yeah
because it's so much harder to go from
online to on the board yeah as opposed
to the other way around yeah yeah yeah
it's like it's weird how much just
playing on that ui just improves your
performance and trying
trying to play with a real-life chess
board is kind of like going from an
automatic car to a manual car you're
like how the [ __ ] does this work i've
completely forgotten everything yeah
yeah that's why you beat me the last
time we played in real life i i think i
had more experience playing over the
board
from like childhood yeah yeah yeah
really a lot of the time it was very
good welsh chess school yeah i guess so
yeah
yeah my experience is just my uncle
beating my ass repeatedly and then
ignoring me for the rest of the day
my dad always wanted to play chess until
i started beating him and then he was
like i don't want to play anymore at
what age were you beating your dad like
ten what yeah was your dad dumb as
bricks
as a kid you have no sense of what is a
good chess player sure first time yeah i
don't know yeah so like you
you've like you're one of like the top
twitch streamers just like in general
was he's one of the he's fell off the
most honestly yeah i i am i do have the
world record for the biggest fall off of
all time from 283 000 subs to zero
no one is close
yeah why because he does like the random
youtube generator and it's like
how this person fell off and then it's
just like always based off like looking
up their social blade and being like you
gone down they are worthless human
rights and it's not substantial yeah and
ninety percent of the time it's just a
minecraft youtuber and yeah i swear
that's like 80 of his channel and then
occasionally you get like i think you've
released like the shane dawson one
recently yeah yeah where yeah yeah well
he calls it a downfall but it's like
he's making more than enough videos
like trying to make it dramatic to pull
in views and yeah
i don't know i mean it's clearly working
it's a boring formula it's the sad
reality of like uh because i was a
journalism student when i went to
college
and there's a
whole semester we spend on like just
general trends
and there was this one news station that
did only good positive news stories for
like a month and their ratings plummeted
yeah yeah and then they went right back
to like sensationalist you know highway
chase bank robber murder in your area
because it just gets more views yeah
yeah i mean that's just true with i
think every platform unfortunately
people just love watching train wrecks
yeah they do they do i do this only
there's not that many actual like big
downfalls on youtube it's just people
just fizzling out of people who quit
like yeah if you quit is it a downfall
like i don't like all your own volitions
yeah i feel like i'm done yeah well
cause yeah like i think we mentioned
this as well like epic meal time right
he just he was like yeah she's not
getting views so i'm i'm quitting it's
like that's not a downfall the dude just
quit but like also sometimes like you
there are creators that just just like
[ __ ] burn out they just need like a
break from the platform but like we've
seen enough people like go off do their
own [ __ ] thing and then just come
back in like a different way or a
different like scene like for example
like ray william johnson become relevant
again through like youtube shorts and
tik tok it's just like so weird so weird
yeah considering like how he was like
kind of like for like the longest time
the staple of like the biggest youtuber
who fell off you know he quit equals
three and nobody ever heard of him and
then now he just did his own thing and
now he's coming back in a different
platform they do so well yeah his shorts
get millions of views
and it's all like cringy roasts
it's literally he's recycling the
formula of equals three but because of
the meta right now it's just working
again yeah yeah and it's so yeah it's
because yeah because i remember i was
like flicking through tick tock and they
just like randomly showed up i was like
yeah oh [ __ ] i completely forgot about
this guy and he's still the exact same
oh he's doing react too yeah yeah so the
thing i saw from him he would find a
tick tocker and he would just roast them
oh he does that yeah yeah yeah yeah he
would just sit there and he'd be like
you look like you've never had sex in
your life you virgin head ass
that was the [ __ ] comedy yeah and
then
they'd be like really mean though and
then he knows ended with a nah i'm just
kidding
[Laughter]
but i guess you can't have success even
that many years i saw i saw a tick tock
where he literally started off being
like check out this video and i'm like
oh my god that the nostalgia wave of
equals three just came back it was
exactly the same formula i think i saw
one that was um it was something about
drake had kind of like blocked off
traffic so you could get out or
something oh yeah yeah this whole thing
was like man doesn't it suck when
celebrities just think they're better
than you guys right like comment
subscribe
like it's like like what is this like
yeah no [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] i i i
yeah i don't know
yeah i mean it's like pandering to you
making you feel like an idiot yeah i
mean it's giving me like more confidence
as a creator because i i see them and
i'm like man if i fall off next year no
problem there's a chance
there's always a chance baby
i would love to see gart in five years
just on tick tock roasting people
i think that is the future for all of us
though right you either the views either
start trending down until you eventually
like quit because you don't want it to
go so down that you're sad yeah or you
pivot to something that like you are
makes you happier that's totally
separate yeah have you ever ever thought
about like at which point do you throw
in the towel do you you know at which
point do you stop huffing the copium and
you realize okay guys it's time it's
time to give a pack it is it's time to
give up you know
yeah yeah it's hard isn't it because
it's like
because if you have enough of a backlog
especially on youtube even if you're not
making like the most amazing views the
backlog can still like kind of save your
offspring it'll make money for years
yeah it'll make money for you as long as
it's all monetized right so it's like
you know some people say like oh if i
get like 0.1 percent of the views that i
used to get then it's like time to pack
it in but there's people who have been
around you know who have those like mega
hits yeah that are still picking up
views that are just like sticking around
even though they make like three four
thousand views of video yeah cause we
were talking about sunny v2 and his
recent shane dawson video he was just
like man shane dawson's views dropped
off by 90
he used to make 40 million views per
video and now he only makes four million
only four and i was like damn i wish i
was making four million views per video
yeah well meanwhile you close at a full
screen and you see his views are like at
two million
who's doing better than you that time i
wish i could be irrelevant with four
million are you [ __ ] kidding me
i think it was a lot different because
when i started streaming i decided i
would only do it for five years yeah
right uh and i and then i was like after
five years i'll stop and then i'll just
have to find something new why five
years because i thought that was a long
time i mean it is it is a live yeah that
was it uh and and i'm at four i'm at
four in may and contractually i have to
do a little over five
god forbid
but it has trended up enough and now i
feel a pressure to keep doing it also
because i have like 15 employees but i
think i'll go a bit longer but i do like
hard capping and like forcing yourself
to either review if this is what you
still want to do or consider other
things to do right what would you do
yeah
wiki feet
that
[Music]
do you know my rating on wiki feed what
is your rating on wiki feed 5.55 how's
that possible i know it waits out of
five stars though i know how's that you
like hacking wiki my grippers are that
good that i have shot above five
where are you ranked on the entire
website i'm i'm i'm the goat
that's that's what we're gonna title
this episode
no faces just your foot
just photoshop it over me for the whole
two hours
your fans will be like oh but yeah i've
never really thought about it because i
guess i'm not there yeah i'm also i'm a
guy who's scared to think of future so i
think very present it's crazy to think
you've only been doing it for four years
though
it's a long time i think you should just
pull up from the subathon right yeah
yeah yeah
no no well i feel like you were you'd
blown up before that and then the
cyberphone just like
like put your propellers oh really i
wish
so okay going into the subathon i
averaged 20 000 viewers
yes holy [ __ ] and then the subathon
happened and it's like
you know neon cat themed planes and i'm
popping off but then it ended and within
60 days i was back down not just to 20
000 but to like 15 to 20 000 average i
was below what i was before the subathon
and in my mind after it ended i was like
i'm a 30k andy now i have i have passed
i am on to the xqc territory right uh
but that's not how it went everyone just
left because they were more interested
in the timer and i realized i never
really showed what my content was
i was just a vegetative state on stream
while a timer played that people were
watching right and so no one actually
knew what i did or cared what i did so
what was the thing that initially blew
you up you think
uh i originally i started to get to like
the thousand views just from like
posting youtube videos yeah that would
and they were doing like well they'd be
like maybe like 100k yeah uh and then it
was pog champs
oh okay
that's what blew you up i went from like
maybe like 5k to like easy like 10 12
even 15k sometimes because i was i was
farming jokes i like would buy books and
i'd make fun of like chess players and
so chess.com would put me on like their
like front screen like it breaks it
would just be me uh and i just used to
like i remember every day i would stream
it would be like an lsf clip and it'd be
like this new streamer is making jokes
on chess website
and i was like yes i am yes i am
and then right after pogchamps ended a
moga's hit
and among us was people don't remember
but it was weirdly competitive to try to
get into lobbies yeah yeah yeah yeah i
mean toast was talking about that to me
as well yeah the other day where it was
it was kind of like there was
you there was like a kind of like circle
where you would always try to get into
the lobby but there was only like nine
nine places right it's ten yeah yeah ten
so even if you circle through people
you're never gonna get through everyone
who wants to join your lobby
yeah so it kind of
weirdly felt like became like political
in a sense very yeah and like the
biggest lobbyists were the otv ones and
they had like obviously their group of
friends that they've had so they would
always have ten but people would drop
after an hour two hours and so i
remember a lot of the times it'd be me
and corp's husband it was before he had
really blown up too and we'd just be
like waiting in the discord and then
it'd be like one spot open and we'd both
be like i'm here i'm here
and then like we'd get in and uh and
eventually like you know you get in
enough times and i think the one thing
that i was good at was being okay with
losing yeah yeah yeah cause a lot of
people are just their egos are so chilly
yeah they just hate being losers but if
you're a really good loser and it's fun
to laugh at you when you lose then it's
fun for other people to play with you
and beat you yeah yeah yeah um so i was
cool with that it's weird to think like
how much among us just catapulted so
many streamers happened to like cutting
seriously when they say among us my
brain is wrong
it is it has a mongoose
but it was really the it was the [ __ ]
it made so many people and it was so
easy too i remember i would watch other
people's streams while streaming and i'd
be at like my peak viewership ever and
i'd be like averaging twenty five
thousand and i'd just be like i'd
and i was like well if i talk over it it
is worse content than if i just shut up
and then i watch germa on my other
monitor right so i just do that
wow damn when's the mix when's the next
among us coming because i feel like has
that was that like the last
massive trends that really just blew up
a lot of streamers or do you think
there's been like something something
else i think what was cool about it is
it everyone was in on it but it opened
up everyone collaborating but now they
collaborate with everything right like
there will be just people
being degenerate in vr chat together or
like rust servers and they're sweatier
or fall guys and they're more casual
yeah but it's just now everyone
collaborates with everyone right right
okay where's among us too man that's
what we're waiting for
i'm i'm waiting for vr
yeah yeah yeah that'll be hyped for two
weeks yeah yeah
and then totally fall off some people
start getting sick of it yeah everyone
hates wearing the headsets yeah exactly
well sodapop is gonna bring his mute to
the vr chat among us and then it's gonna
be weird
it's gonna get all problematic oh my god
oh my god
that's gonna be an interesting time yeah
yeah yeah so like you do a lot of events
now and stuff like that is that
something you've always wanted to like
work yourself like work up towards where
you can get this freedom and just to do
a lot of different fun events like
how how did that idea come about way
where you just wanted to like do
tournaments and do events and do like
mogul money and stuff like that yeah i
think they're always the thing that
i feel like if you're at a a successful
point streaming and you get a [ __ ] ton
of money you should put effort back in
yeah and events always seem to be
successful yeah uh and i mean honestly i
think the goat is germa
yeah
he's like so original i i saw his like
he did the sims like the dollhouse one
jim's dollhouse yeah [ __ ] insane yeah
like it's insane like his brain comes up
with that and i know he has like a few
coming up that are like he's told me
about and like he did one that i did
with him where he had uh he was in like
a room and he had a clipboard and you
had people dressed like him oh yeah so
to try to replace him yeah and then it
was a reveal that it was a replaced
germa show and it was like uh america's
next top model or whatever one of those
game shows with buzzers and like he's
just has an insane mind for it but i'm
not nearly as original so i think i'm
doing more of like the e-buy route and
like you you probably saw his stream
he got the the viewership record three
yeah three million right yeah yeah i
thought my twitch had glitched when i
logged on to twitch yeah i saw that he
had more than all of twitch combined and
it's cause like he did an event and i i
don't think he's like nearly as original
as creative as drama but he's doing
events to such like a high level that
it's like every week you tune in and
it's like oh he's doing a mogul money oh
he's doing a boxing event oh he's doing
a cooking show and i think that's the
goal is to get to there right yeah
because one thing that i always respect
about that is
you know it's different being a youtuber
doing an event versus i think doing
being a twitch event and doing an event
because you know we can like plan big
projects big videos but we can edit that
you know we can pre-film that we can
edit out stuff that doesn't work you
guys are doing it live right which takes
like i'd argue like double the team to
be able to make like 10 times the
planning as well yeah yeah yeah like the
dollhouse thing like i don't i can't
even like imagine how much how many
staff members he needed to run that live
yeah this episode is sponsored by
expressvpn guys watching netflix without
using expressvpn it's like going to the
theme park and only being allowed to go
on one ride why would you do that it
might not even be the best ride there
guys you've probably realized by now
that netflix doesn't give you everything
you've been paying for you can unlock
every single content library by just
changing your location to different
locations and expressvpn allows you to
do that joey what have you been watching
on netflix recently you know since we
mentioned it so much on trash taste i
thought you know i want to go back to
the classics watch them always sunny but
unfortunately it's not available but
thankfully thanks to expressvpn i can
unlock it with a quick and easy step i
just open the app i select the country
tap one button and then boom i'm
connected and i can watch every single
episode of always sunny guys let me tell
you why you should choose expressvpn
over other vpns tell me it's got blazing
fast speeds thank god you can stream in
hd with zero buffering so be smart stop
paying full price for streaming services
and only getting a fraction of their
content get your money's worth at
expressvpn.com trash taste don't forget
to use our link at expressvpn.com
to get an extra three months free of
expressvpn come on joey say the line
back to the episode like how many staff
members do you have to like help you
just function with the stuff that you do
i have 15 full-time employees right now
holy [ __ ] damn who i hire
[ __ ] that's this is and you're just
one guy i'm just a dude three you i
think you hire more people right now
than we do yeah
yeah all of us combined yeah yeah
it's it's it's helpful
because what you find out is like okay
you do need a huge team to do all of
this and it's much better if it's
in-house as opposed to reaching out to
someone else to do it all right because
then there's like onboarding and they
might not do it right and you can't
really get mad at them because you know
they're just doing that they're doing
their job i think i think we figured out
how much work and effort it takes to
plan like a live show when we did like
our 24-hour charity stream yeah and even
that was like i think like pretty simple
compared to some of the stuff you guys
are doing but that took like months and
months of planning
um
and like yeah even still it was like
[ __ ] hard to pull off as well yeah
just because you get to stay up yeah
yeah yeah like the schedule crumbled by
the second half because we're all just
so [ __ ] dead yeah because we plan to
do like six or seven other things in the
second half and we're all just like oh
let's just read donations for the next
two hours i remember watching and it was
like a period where you all looked like
you had taken ketamine and you're
reading donations and you're just in a
daze like
connor you were just like thank you
and like people were talking next to you
and you i don't even think you were in
it i was completely dead i don't know
why it was such a good event though yeah
it was really fun yeah we really want to
do another one yeah i mean i i like the
i like the idea of doing the other one
but i remember the last seven to eight
hours of that stream and i just i just
like
we need we need somewhere to like rotate
out or something guys
that was that was hard just do like
eight eight eight or something or just
have one person sleep while the other
person
it's like when old military people would
be on guard and then yeah the other
people rest then you swap yeah i think
we made the mistake of drinking when
chris came on and then like like like
after we stopped drinking when he came
off that's when it like truly hit and
that's when like uh
like cider and he's like boys
and i was like oh
[ __ ]
not gonna say no
i
wondered why you don't stream on youtube
i think i talked to you about that you
guys
because you guys are so big on youtube
like you're the biggest podcast i feel
like in terms of floor
or one of the on youtube and i was like
oh it makes so much sense to just stream
on youtube you'd probably get a bunch of
viewers but then you're like everyone go
to twitch yeah i don't know i don't know
why we decided to go for twitch instead
of youtube
maybe one day they can sign us right
yeah
this is what this is like
twitch stays on top
because when you're like where do i live
stream you're like twitch
yeah i don't know i mean we
we didn't really have much plans
regarding the live streaming it was kind
of like an experiment the experiment
turned out really really [ __ ] well
and then we are kind of like figuring
things out as we go along because i
think always our youtube is our main
priority and then the the after dark
twitch streams were just
things that we wanted to do on the sides
um and yeah and twitch is pretty helpful
they've given us some more incentives to
stream on their platform as well which
is good which youtube hasn't
so it's kind of like what you have a
platform is like hey we'll we'll help
you we'll give you reasons you're like a
kid and it's like just a old truck
waving candy in front of you yeah you're
like yes yeah i mean like i mean because
the platforms do the same thing really
yeah i mean
whichever one is willing to help you out
more and give you more tools to do what
you need to do
we just went for the truck that had more
candy yeah there's a lot of candy
how's the changeover been from let's
twitch to youtube oh
terrible
yeah i think um
i had the foresight to ask one of uh
like the people i hire he's a developer
his name's otto to make an extension
that would make the the transition much
more seamless and that's been a godsend
because i don't know if you've ever been
in a youtube chat
it's miserable the delay is terrible
yeah the messages flow like water and
you can barely read them you feel like
you're going crazy yeah yeah and
everyone is just like a youtube normie
so they're all just kind of not fun to
talk to how haven't they fixed that it
seems so simple to fix because they have
like a
million employees and are bloated in our
scene you had like susan you know do you
know excuse to fix it i can be but then
she'll be like yeah and they'll do like
eight months of analysis and research
and then figure out how to fix it and
then decide if they want to fix it yeah
they're just slow and i think they will
it'll just be like in two years
right i'd i realized yesterday after
going on the yard right that susan had
to go up those ladders yeah you made
susan go up like ladders together
i did [ __ ] dude susan
i interviewed her on the yard saying
yeah yeah susan would just be the uh
what ladder is this
to get to my podcast room uh we
basically changed a closet into just
like a ladder room and it's kind of like
a fireman ladder it's literally a
vertical ladder that's your closet it
was a it was it was a closet then we
just change it into that because the
only other way to get in is like it's
one of those attic doors that you need
to pull down with a string right but it
goes into my roommate's aiden's room and
it like it leaves dust everywhere so we
don't like to use it so i offered twos
in that and it's like more you know
diagonal and she was like no i want to
go up the ladder
and i was like all right bet
no help though
how did that happen
susan thing yeah i i tweeted at her
jokingly while doing the podcast yeah
and i'll because they were like oh
they're like do you talk to susan i'm
like yeah i'm close to that i'm tired
with her so i just as a meme i was like
come on my podcast and then she
talked to like the people who hired me
to youtube and she was like man i'm down
like let's see if we can set it up and
then she actually came and she was super
nice she's like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] i was
[ __ ] i was nervous joking well okay
what's [ __ ] okay so
we started joking before she was gonna
come on cause she knew we knew she was
coming on yeah about about susan and we
made some we make some not so savory
jokes
you know uh we made some jokes about
about dogs who run a clinic and in the
clinic they are scientists and they test
by having sex with adult women anyways
the point of this joke
i don't know where it spawned conor it
just happened it happened okay and the
joke devolved to a point because we kept
running with it and no one wanted to end
it we were talking about a doberman
named bruce having sex with susan and
we're all laughing about this
and then susan
reaches out to my partner manager and
she's like what's a good episode of the
yard to listen to
and he's like
he listens he's like i'll give you one
and she's like no i want to listen to
the most recent one
and he's like no you don't
she's like no i i really do
and so i i think she listened to it and
i think she's so aware of the content
that happens yeah that she was cool with
it she was like oh i get it like you're
just making content and you're doing
anything to make jokes around yeah and
she was cool with it but i was like that
was the most nervous i was it's like
when she came and i was like i'm gonna
get yelled at
i'm sorry so what was that about dogs
i would be mortified yeah
it's like a teacher calling you into
their classroom so i saw the note that
you were passing around in the classroom
i watched the whole thing it was really
good you killed it yeah it went great
and i think it was i think it was good
like it made her seem like a human
because i don't think
because like i just genuinely don't
think people get to see her a lot yeah
yeah yeah the whole science laboratory
yeah and she's and she is formed in a
lab of course like all ceos
did you have to do a lot of prep for
that episode because like whenever we
have guests on we we just do like zero
prep yes it's been eye-opening like
going on like other podcasts and meeting
other creators having like [ __ ]
talking points laid out and i'm like
[ __ ] man
what are we we should probably do that
we should probably do that
we do the same thing when we have guests
uh
but with this one i had to tell them
everything i was going to do
because
she has like a team yeah she's like
content person social media person
youtube person and they all hopped in a
meeting they're like what do you want to
do and i was like i want to get an nft
of homer simpson spreading his [ __ ]
and then say i bought an nft and they're
like no
i want to bring in a doberman you know
i couldn't believe you showed the pepe
uh emer oh that was golden i didn't tell
him about that oh you just did it that's
the one thing i did because i told him
about everything and i was like well i
really want to catch her off guard and
so then i was like i'll show a picture
of a pepe hanging himself which maybe
wasn't the classiest idea yeah were they
annoyed about that no no the actually
the only thing because there was
literally a watch party downstairs in my
living room while i was happening and i
could hear laughter like through every
part and so i knew i was killing it when
they would laugh but there was one part
where i came down after and they were
like yeah everyone viscerally cringed
and it was when i said the word come
on
and i was like wow i'm shocked because i
showed them so much worse things i
thought yeah you said the word come in
what context
uh because i talked about how my
girlfriend's podcast gets demonetized
and it was just a broader intro to
demonetization and i was like well our
podcast we talk about [ __ ] and come a
lot
just to like that's what we do
and then and then
apparently they were just they were like
losing it downstairs and just devolving
into like
like among a sus picture face
yeah yeah and that was it oh my god i
can accept a frog hanging yourself but i
draw the line i shouldn't come
let's be classy
i think we're we're we're in trouble as
well
just had a hentai artist on recently
that was that was an interesting
conversation on their show and they were
like uh so you're you're uncircumcised
right sorry yeah i was like what
are you boy you gotta be on secret side
yeah that is our intro question yeah
yeah this has to be an uncut couch
i believe this is all uncut wow this is
an honor
you you guys should know that we've seen
each other's [ __ ] we're all dicks
because we're not from america huh we're
not from america they all they also they
also yeah yeah yeah for some reason
that's why we don't have the
conversation because we already we've
already seen each other's dicks because
you're like onsens in japan and
everything like we're aware of each
other's circumcision circumstances
conor told me that we went rock climbing
and there's a shower and obviously like
there's curtains and dividers but after
he's like yeah just so you know like
i've seen joey's dick
they were asking like they were like i
think we sent came out about onsen i was
like you see each of the sticks yeah
that's what you do and they're like what
what can i ask a question yeah sure okay
i i know what he's going to ask
what are you
would this let me into an onsen could i
cover it or is that no you're good with
that you're going to no you're doing it
you're good with that yeah go i thought
you were just about to i think you're
going to pull your dick out
you're going to be like where do i where
do i stand them
thinking about starting a wiki dick you
know out of five you know what
i got the tattoo and my first fear was
now i can never go into a japanese onsen
you could also just wear if you're
really worried about it just put a
band-aid on it but isn't that like rude
no no no no no
i thought it was like sacred and i would
be tainting the water with my you know
what's been more tainting and if you had
blood everywhere and puss all in there
yeah i guess that's fair just put it no
one cares about a band if you're really
really worried about just put a band-aid
on yeah yeah yeah yours is small enough
where like people won't even see it
just don't even care really yeah i'd be
really impressed you're kicked out for
that okay yeah yeah it has to be like a
really traditional place to be kicked
out like that yeah like no you know also
why they're looking yeah yeah he's like
why why look at that
yeah like damn you do leg day yeah yeah
cause cause the thing with onsen people
people think that you just like go
around staring at each other's dicks and
all that stuff and it's just like no
it's just in your periphery for 10
minutes yeah yeah yeah yeah you
acknowledge
like maybe 15 if it's like a good dick
i need a good gander yeah
would you go down son then you want to
oh i would love to yeah i'm dying too i
mean i'm dying to go to japan as a whole
as i'm sure every guest you've had you
haven't been yet right i think you're
the most obsessed with japan of any of
the guests
yeah well you applied for the jet
program i did and i got declined in
record pace why did you why did you get
declined i don't know i thought it was i
mean i know that i know the selection
process is really tough yeah i thought
they left anyone on
it was very different all those years
ago yeah
it's like our economy isn't shaped right
now do
no when i applied i went to like a whole
seminar because i graduated from arizona
state
and uh which which is a university where
they actually check your heartbeat and
they let you in yeah uh and i got a
degree in english and journalism right
and uh and i had recently broke up my
girlfriend uh and i was like you know at
that pivotal point where i'm like what
do i do with my life yeah i was like
[ __ ] it i'll go to japan yeah uh and i
applied and i thought i was a standout
and they're like no shot and i was like
oh
and like in preparation for it that's i
think what i originally like that's
where i found chris and i was like okay
i have to watch abroad in japan videos
because i have to know the seven things
i can't do in japan
i would hate to do those
uh and then i just i've literally
continued to watch it as if i'm applying
every year right even though i have no
ability to go to japan yeah right yeah
you've never been to japan never know
yeah because i remember you were saying
uh like before your twitch channel
popped off you used to watching a lot of
like japan based creators and like japan
based like twitch streamers and stuff
like that first guy sub two was retro
gaijin yeah oh damn he was just he's
just a dude from like ohio who lives in
i think tokyo now uh and i watched him
back in the day like seven years ago and
he just used to play smash 4 which is my
favorite game back then too and i was
like okay japan cool smash cool
combo right right uh and yeah and so
it's like i'm still
i still watch him i watch pretty much
every japan creator i've seen them at
some point right you know uh so i think
i'm going in
not disillusioned not thinking anime
will rain down from the skies and pretty
aware of everything for subtitles yeah
well wait wait
let's do something right
after the olympics yeah yeah
uh and i i i still think it'll be really
tight yeah yeah yeah you'll love it is
there anything in particular you want to
do there now because like it seems like
out of every creator you've
you've been in like indirectly involved
in the japanese youtube community just
because you consume so much of it yeah i
think because of that it that will
influence a lot of what i do like i want
to go to dogen's place because it seems
so tight oh yeah yeah i really want to
go as well uh and and he offered because
i i hit him that right after he got i
hit him with that sly like nice house
be a shame if you didn't have someone in
there filling it up
that guest room looks awfully yeah
exactly
uh
and like like all the classics like
okinawa i want to go to aomori because
that seems tight
as [ __ ] yeah uh
and yeah when i go i think i'll go for a
month and i'll just live there for a
month yeah
don't go during the summer months though
no yeah yeah yeah it seems brain dead to
go yeah
i hate being here and it's probably
worse than here like it's ten times
worse than here yeah it's here but just
up the humidity by 90 yeah which is
miserable it is because it sucks here
like you go outside it's 95 uv's like a
10 you're burning instantly i think i
think yesterday was like 110 120
something like that yeah which is
[ __ ] disgusting yeah that's the time
when we don't leave our houses like
right yeah i think the tokyo i got i saw
an article was like tokyo government was
asking people to not leave their lights
on after three or something because
they're they're so short electricity
powering all the ac yeah yeah [ __ ] dudes
yeah mcconaughey's like ac on 24 7
it's running right now just waiting for
him to come back yeah yeah yeah i want
to keep it at the same time
it's more expensive to turn it on and
off yeah exactly
yeah i mean i'm i i get like heat stroke
and i faint and [ __ ] if it's too hot
yeah like i pretty much should have it
on all the time yeah
um during the summer especially it's
brutal yeah there's a lot of people who
like pass out and die from the
heatstroke
whales we don't have that we don't know
i don't have that in the states either i
mean like unless someone's like hiking
on the appalachian trail and then it's
like or you're in arizona which like you
decided to live there your fault
you're from new hampshire right yes is
that pretty cool is that nice it gets
humid and like muggy but it gets like
you know not too bad oh okay in terms of
temperature what is new hampshire famous
for
we have one of the worst presidents of
all time franklin pierce who committed
genocide amongst native americans
and also a cool mountain oh okay well
maybe you start off with the mountain
you know yeah it was called old man on
the mountain and it was just a mountain
that looked like it had a face on it and
then it fell
because the face was so heavy so now
it's just a mountain yeah and now it's
just like a normal mountain but we still
call it that when we drive by and we're
like it was our 911.
never forget baby
i like how that's the that's the
equivalent to americans like is it a bad
thing it's it's it's the 911 yeah it's
the you know that is the worst thing
that could happen
nothing worse has ever happened no in
the history
uh yeah that's that's it it's a small
small state and you're you're the
biggest youtuber in your school right no
i know yeah [ __ ] you
are you nuts i i went to a school it's a
hollis brooklyn they had to combine two
towns and our graduating class was like
relatively small it's like 200 people uh
and i'm not the biggest youtuber who
graduated from that school i just want
to ask you that because there's this
annoying least big successful fortnight
youtuber who's like mister top five
it'll be like top five fortnight
glitches in season eight act three pro
prague
that's like five and by then he'll find
he'll be on the roblox high dude
he's the emmy he's like he's like dude
went to the same school and i i don't
have the heart to message him back
because all i feel is angered towards it
don't talk to me that's i'm like i'm
like here's a podcast from susan
he's also younger than me oh yeah
are you like a senior class or whatever
i'm older than us
even more yeah so like i'm supposed to
be cooler i'm i was a senior you were a
freshman
so that's right i'm the biggest youtuber
from my school
oh yeah of the 20.
are you the biggest welsh youtuber
no i think there's someone who did like
fifa or something
idiotic
you're the biggest youtuber from your
school i mean i am i mean i would be the
biggest youtuber in my city until
[ __ ] pewdiepie moved here
but even then seldom jack we've got
jacksepticeye there yeah you know i got
a ways to catch up but they can't they
came into my territory you know i feel
like
yeah you know i i was like born and
raised there now if by that metric i
wouldn't be the biggest youtuber in the
world i don't live there anymore but
native you know are you native to
brighton yeah yeah i was born and raised
in brighton yeah that's like isn't that
like an amazing town to be like raised
in it's like beautiful right yeah yeah i
mean right like now it is it wasn't even
like a city when i was like growing up
there um it was just like a small town
and then suddenly it became i guess now
like the san francisco i guess of the uk
yeah now it's like the youtube hub of
the uk yeah everyone lives there yeah
yeah yeah every youtuber i've met yeah
either you go to london and like you
hate life or whatever yeah uh or you
move to brighton and just have a great
time because it's just good vibes what
can i say it'll be well soon the whales
will be the hubble well
climb eight mountains if you pass the
bar
you get one one megabyte upload down
yeah yeah
cheap houses
yeah i imagine cheaper than here way
cheaper i'll give you that bro
anything's cheaper than here you did
that uh that uh one video it was like uh
what can you get for like a million
dollars did you do whales
no
i did like well i did like the click
baity ones
japan gets clicks america gets clicks
close clicks dude welsh flag does not
get it get clicks dude it's cliff you
just think kids are like dragons yeah
everyone's like dragon dudes this is a
cool dragon
the one welsh person trying to get like
welsh culture up there i'm trying my
best dude i'm trying to then they won't
do it for some reason the welsh board of
marketing or whatever the [ __ ] is not
doing anything you could probably like
say hey i want to start a channel with
you guys you pay for it all and you just
teach welsh lessons once a week who
would i talk to he's the [ __ ] guy you
like upload youtube you talk to the
welsh guy i don't know there's like
seven
it's like seven of us dude just go do
you know any other welsh youtubers
actually well i think about it no
no not at all
no one can understand them you know i
think i told about this story there was
a there was this tv show uh that was
produced by like the because the wet
wells has their own like tv uh i don't
know [ __ ] what are you called network
syndicate yeah and they had this
documentary which was like about
successful welsh youtubers and i was so
pissed off they didn't ask me
you weren't on it no because they they
had got someone who had like 10 000 subs
i i'm not like a guy who's like i don't
give a [ __ ] about numbers but at that
one time i was like are you [ __ ]
kidding me
i would have said yes they didn't even
reach out to me wait were you living in
wales at the time though no but that's
even more that's probably where there's
more hype though come see me in japan
dude from wales that's awesome like it's
a that's a success story your accent's
not thick enough for them anymore i
could have brought it back
so you know i just make these videos in
japan you see and i i go around and i
talk to the natives
and we make these fun videos like i
would have done it whatever they wanted
i would have done it i would have been
flexing anything i was so annoyed they
didn't ask me and i'm like yeah i just
thought come on you even there's there's
more than people with ten thousand subs
there's someone else you could have gone
you should bring them up and be like do
you know who i am well i think that's
where like it was just the production
company were just like yeah we found
this guy he seems to be doing something
well well oh that's just she's good
enough like followers there's probably
clickbait they probably found the guy
and then they were like oh we'll make
this segment yeah not like we'll make
the segment we'll find the guy yeah and
the person who was the youtuber had like
a full-time job as well and i'm like
that's like what the [ __ ] is the point
of this
it's not even their main stick it's like
just home videos
i i'm just like come on guys what do you
what do they have in wales is it a
president uh we do have a pro we have a
prime minister prime minister yeah be
that go be that
i don't think it's that easy how many
people live in wales
three million just run for oh that's
pretty big well
uh england is like 60 million i mean
yeah it's i know it's not that big but
it's like it's bigger than i thought
it'd be yeah well it's more than
northern ireland so we're not the not
the smallest right hey you're not isle
of man
well
you always got that who wants to be the
island exactly yeah i mean christmas
chris says it's nice though
yeah i thought it's really good i
haven't been myself well like
i'm really amazing
i'm always when someone says like
there's a really nice spot to travel to
in the uk because i'm just like
oh like why what like
why would you travel to the uk when you
could travel out of the uk and
experience something even nicer you know
what i mean
people go around england and england are
just the same [ __ ] different places well
i went to england my first time and i
went to a beautiful town do you know
stoke on trent
you went to stoke-on-trent yeah
lovely vacation there
where is it it's north of uh london yeah
why would you go why why why why in all
of the uk did you choose i just started
i thought it'd be lovely and it seemed
uh staffordshire you went all the way to
a a for a
smash tournament was it worth it
no
no not i mean it was still fun but i
have i've definitely gone to like i used
to go to smash tournaments and that'd be
like my main reason to go somewhere yeah
like you guys with conventions right
right that's just what a smash
tournament is
uh but then i was like you know what
traveling is exhausting and i cannot do
youtube or stream when i'm doing it yeah
and i've i've gone away less i don't
know if you've noticed that with
conventions right it's like harder to
sign up to go to one
yeah yeah i mean that's that's why we
[ __ ] took our equipment here so we
can work on the road and make content
but other than that i mean i think the
reason we're traveling so much this year
is just because we spend like two
[ __ ] years of pandemic and we just
want to travel
um yeah but yeah we needed to get out
yeah right yeah we were like i've never
been like stir crazy in a country before
but that's how i felt after two years of
japan love japan i just miss
speaking english sometimes you know
right that was a massive thing
um but what was your experience of
british culture then
it was pretty chill uh you know the
tesco meal deal is great i went to a
casino everyone was really nice uh the
taxi drivers were way too comfortable
talking about doing cocaine
and
stoke on trend right yeah
outside of that just something to do
yeah yeah great we'll be back again 10
out of 10. nice indian spot cool uh but
certainly not my number one vacation no
well i don't have you been to like
london at all like you've seen london a
bit we went when we did the podcast with
asa butterfield to london right uh and
that was that was chill but i also find
like i i i went first day i went to
coventry to do a podcast with tommy and
i and i i feel bad when i'm just like
i'll just vacation and hang out yeah so
i didn't like do that i just worked the
whole time i recorded super auto pets
vods
in my hotel room for like a few hours
instead of going out was that the same
hotel that i sent yeah yeah yeah dude
they did not have a desk how did you do
that uh the mine did might have like a
little desk i can have a desk and i was
and i was just playing super auto pets
it was just a game live or just no just
recorded why
because they did well on youtube and
so i but i don't feel like i should
permit myself to just you know just have
time have a night on the town go get
your dreams why not like now you're
signed now so now he doesn't know how
much doesn't that much pressure maybe
i'm also i think i think i'm anxious
after covet to just like go out to a pub
alone and just be like
oyoy and just were
no solo this episode is sponsored by pc
specialists pc specialists are one of
the leading custom pc manufacturers in
europe specializing in gaming pcs
laptops workstations and a whole lot
more did you know that they focus on
building high performance systems for
gamers enthusiasts content creators
that's us and professionals we wish
that's not us they have an easy to use
configuration allowing you to customize
each component of your build to your own
desire each pc is meticulously cable
managed to ensure neatness and tested to
ensure stability and performance all of
their pcs are powered by windows 11
playtime anytime thank god hell yeah you
can order now with the link on screen or
just click the link in the description
and use code trash at checkout but be
warned guys that this is for a limited
time only be in for a chance to win big
with an epic free pc gaming setup worth
over get this 4
000 pounds
with intel asus rog and its pc
specialist during intel gaming days more
info at the pc specialist website terms
and conditions apply back to the episode
well next time we got to come to a cool
city like brighton no no no no come
surprise brighton's so overrated it's
probably nice
you're comparing it to what whales
they're like oh we've got like a seaside
and the beach is like mid it's like a
really mediocre beach i stayed in the
worst hotel of my life in brighton
really by far the worst hotel ever what
did you where did you stay it was the
one right next to the pier okay well you
don't stay near the pier you know but
it's like it's like this giant hotel and
the best location in brighton you'd
think it's this historical building and
somehow they just made this like just a
miserable experience just like i walked
into the room and it was just mold
everywhere and then you go to the
bathtub like i'll take a shower this
black [ __ ] all over the bathtub you're
like what the [ __ ] and they charged
money for this and then i went to boil
the cattle that's usually how hotels
work yeah
and so i went to boil the cattle to make
a cup of tea because at least if there's
one salvation life i can have a cup of
tea yeah i can have that
i go there and the coil in the kettle is
just rust just completely rusted and i'm
like what the f these are like five
pounds to get the shittest kettle
because the hotel cattles are the worst
ones yeah this is the british problem uh
i can't believe they deprive you of this
just artistic human right in the uk that
is a basic human yeah
in the uk the hotel room will have like
they won't have fridges but they'll
always have a kettle yeah yeah you know
did you notice they didn't know they
would not provide toothbrush and
toothpastes
but they will have a cat they'll always
have a channel because you need tea yeah
you'll be in like a one-star hotel it's
like a like a [ __ ] mattress on the
floor and there'll be somehow a kettle
there you know we used to go to like
france right uh like
every year for like three weeks my mom
would always bring a kettle with her oh
because they don't have it in france
because they actually one of the she
wanted to make tea yeah yeah and in
france you're just taking a shot of
espresso
moving on with your dad be rude to
someone on the street instead that's how
you get your kicks for the day yeah
yeah they're nice in southern france
maybe like outside of paris yeah yeah in
paris they're dicks but that's also the
charm like you want that no no i know
yeah it's like a it's like a fed you
want him to like spit on you and be like
just go to downtown
nothing experiencing you speak french i
speak french yeah so you probably had a
better time because you speak french
what will happen to me is because i
speak french but i speak kind of like a
seven-year-old and everyone in paris
speaks english so sometimes like it
depends but i'll speak french and then
they'll reply in english and i'll just
be like no because i i got i got denied
entry into a restaurant because i didn't
speak french oh that wouldn't happen to
me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
that's rude yeah yep probably racist
yeah
i think that's like the the definition
the definition of race guys are saying
like you want that like
well it's such a great experience part
of the chart yeah got kicked out i was
frosting at the mouth
right and sucks that was the main point
yeah that's fair i i disagree of course
i would well why wouldn't i right
brian's an actual cool city in the uk i
can't believe you're like digging on
bryce you've never been to wales huh
you've never been to wales what's in
wales you're gonna have a look cheap uh
it's actually this really cool youtuber
ten thousand subs he's my favorite you
gotta caught it from what's going on
that's not a tourist sport just has like
a castle in the middle of the city how
[ __ ] sick is that this is a castle
can you go in it yeah oh then that's
cool yeah right i'm on board there's no
castles in
brighton there's like a rondael castle
which is like pretty damn close actually
it's not like it's destroyed
no it's working you can go in there
they're yeah fighting out of it right
now yeah
casuals are either working or ruins
uh what is your thoughts on english
breakfast
i mean i love english breakfast i
wouldn't have it every day but it's true
oh wait you wouldn't have 2 000 calories
at 8 a.m every day it's too much you
know the heaven whale's actually the
best english breakfast ever in in wales
ironically
did i call it a welsh breakfast you try
to single-handedly double the tourism of
whales in this podcast there's this one
place uh near where i grew up and uh
it's just like it's a farm right and the
whole point is that all the farms come
together and they all bring their
produce to the store it's like a hipster
kind of thing and so they make their own
everything like baked beans i've never
seen homemade baked beans i didn't even
know it existed i thought heinz had the
monopoly yeah they've owned all the beef
i just thought you weren't it was like
illegal to make beans it didn't come in
the heinz can but they made everything
fresh the egg yolk was so amazing it was
like bright red so raw it was amazing
mushrooms all fresh bread was baked
there bro it was game-changing it sounds
great i i can't have english breakfast i
mean that's communal right like that's
that's the that's the pen ultimate
breakfast you can yeah and it was
expensive but it was good it was amazing
i mean like a british like english
breakfast is one of the few british
cuisines i'm actually proud of you know
there's no there's not there's not many
in england it's pretty [ __ ] good too
yeah but i just can't have it more than
three days in a row like shepherds and
cottage pie it's bad i mean i think it's
i think it's better than american
breakfast
no what's wrong with having 80 grams of
sugar at 9am what are you talking about
why why did you guys trick yourselves
into eating dessert for breakfast yeah
why did you guys think pancakes were a
breakfast food yeah it's cause when
you're a kid growing up there's like a
cute bunny and he's like wow
eat my cereal
do you eat breakfast uh yeah i have a
protein shake in a banana
i have a boring breakfast i'm gonna say
that's pretty because cereal is terrible
for you yeah it's awful and all not
having grand slam years
but hey they go hard i do like uh like
pancakes protein pancakes what protein
pancakes yeah you can get like pancakes
that are like infused with like protein
powder oh so you get like glyphosates
different oil put proteins you can't
really tell because i lather peanut
butter on it i love peanut butter oh
right right so that's just my [ __ ] you
know what if they changed british
breakfast to be called english brunch
i'm on board well it's not meant to be
eaten traditionally as a breakfast oh
yeah yeah oh english breakfast isn't no
no no when is english breakfast meant to
be eaten connor okay lunch yeah
basically you have a hard night you need
a late lunch you need you need a
hangover cure and that's when
you got to change the name to brunch
it's a marketing problem but british
people don't get brunch that's like
they wouldn't understand the combination
of words
i don't know if uh english breakfast was
made in like south england or north
england yeah because in north england
they don't say lunch
we don't say the word lunch what do you
say dinner yeah they say dinner oh
that's right oh and supper it's
breakfast tea
tea for dinner so when i when i was
growing up i would be my mom would be
like oh i'd be like when's dinner and
that's like 12 o'clock and then when
when's tea which is it like
that's so weird
what was that [ __ ] face you just you
just you just made up a word like let's
say i said no tears how's tea made of
wood let's have ladder
you guys want that's drinks
it's it's been around for i don't know
how long it's been around for actually
that's the point look you made the
language i can't be mad
you guys skewed it you i i am assuming
it was it was bastardized into lunch
yeah maybe it was always dinner and then
americans were like no this is too
complicated
that's just a northern thing you know we
say lunch down in the south i wonder
which one who started what came first
which one changed what came first your
dinner which one
checkmate when you look at the map what
side is like the like the colloquially
dumber side or like more rural not
necessarily [ __ ] day yeah
are you trying to start a civil war
like who are the dumb idiots that
deserve nothing
yeah well typically the north has always
been poorer yeah okay
of all time because you rephrase it in a
way that makes you the hero and me the
villains
he lives in the rich south yeah swirling
his martinis while i'm swirling my iron
brew infused with a shot of vodka i'm
just crying just trying to make it
through the winter you haven't had an
iron brew no oh my god what's that
that's a oh wait you don't know iron
bruise
it's a scottish drink and it's just it's
kind of popular up north it's this drink
that's filled with sugar it's awful it's
all has more sugar than curry i think
americans would love it because it's so
sweet yeah yeah well have you guys have
had rupiah right yes i love you really
yeah it's [ __ ] vile i gave it to
conor he hated it
it's like poor man's medicine i don't
know it just tastes like [ __ ] that's dr
pepper
pepper tastes good pepper is good nah dr
pepper tastes too mediciney for me
that's that's the medicine taste we
gotta we gotta get every soda and do a
soda tear list while you guys are still
here
we need to go through it yeah one thing
about going back to like north and south
divide like a big debate in the uk is
where like even the south and the north
begins
because there's this place uh called the
midlands right and i don't even think
the midlands exists you know because
anything above anything above london is
the north to me right now yeah does
where where where does the north begin
for uconn it's a it's a lo it's
literally been like there have been
studies on this it's like a diagonal
line
right where it's kind of not like a
everyone wish it was a horizontal line
but it's diagonal because you don't want
to throw whales in there well no because
whales would be considered north right
that's why it's diagonal yes if it
wasn't wales would be part of the south
no it would be probably part of the
north i'd imagine that hostile yeah
which part of wales
because like wales is kind of in the
middle right yeah so it's kind of i
don't know
one of the major cities in the south or
the north uh what like cardiff god of
south yeah which would be south south
yeah i'm not from cardiff all right
i'm from the north you're from the poor
section yeah
again the poorer of wales which is all
poor
and i didn't even get the documentary to
be on the welsh biggest youtuber
no w's from wales
i think my favorite thing i've heard
about the midlands is who who who are
you hanging out that said they went to
birmingham and they were like i
understand why they call it the midlands
yeah i forgot who it was it was like
yeah i was like uh
i think it was one of my friends from
high school because he lives in the uk
now and he was like yeah i went to
birmingham the other day and i was like
why'd you go to birmingham and he's like
i have a friend who lives in birmingham
it's like it was pretty mid i think
that's why they're called the midlands
man stoke on trent this is beautiful
it's above birmingham i just looked at
where it was yeah i thought it was like
in the middle
oh my god wait so birmingham is the
south now birmingham
midlands
although that's what people from
birmingham would say yeah like an hour
uh struggling trend is like an hour
drive from where i grew up
really yeah well it's a lovely town you
should go visit it with your family
you gotta smash tony yeah
why was there i don't even wanna know
did you have a fish and chips while
you're there i haven't actually ever had
fish and chips in the uk oh
i refuse i don't think you guys would do
fries correct what the [ __ ]
your fries suck here wendy's bro come on
you had those fries were good but like
thick fries from like uh fat burger that
was terrible yeah yeah you guys can't
you guys can do like thick cut fries no
or chips but i also don't want them i
want them fried salty with a bunch of
msg and i want to feel like a little
tubbo guy that's what i enjoy doing
it's a greedy endeavor when you even
attempt to eat fries i love the thick
fries though
i actually enjoyed the taste of potato
yeah
what
i know
you're not eating it for oil and salt
wow okay unfortunately not yeah
interesting
you know it depends on the mood mostly i
prefer like thin cup but you know
sometimes you just want a nice thick
bite of potato i want to think [ __ ]
yeah
all the time
with the sauce yeah respect that yeah
did you try any other british food while
you were there no i tried to avoid
generally
we have the tesco meal deal right tesco
meal deal goes hard yeah it's very good
uh and i don't mind that but everything
else
i didn't go to greg's once nando's i did
go to nando's but that's not british
food i mean we try to pretend it's
british food yeah because it's one of
the only things we can well like like
everything in britain we we take it from
another country and then just say it's
ours yeah yeah
that's cool let's put our history for a
very long time i guess that you are the
literal kings of that yeah yeah
yeah because like in a lot of indian
restaurants they uh like serve chicken
tikka masala and that's that's a british
dish well scottish actually okay okay is
it yeah yeah
it wasn't invented in india it was
invented tikka tikka is like a
scottish thing like the way of cooking
the chicken i see that's like a scottish
thing i don't know that it's a scottish
dish so if you've ever had a chicken
tikka masala yeah when i go into the
indian restaurant that i local i'll say
this is scottish just so you know
just so you know but they're like i
think like most indian restaurants in
the uk are run by bangladesh people
anyway yeah so i mean you're not even
getting an authentic experience it's
close well it's like it's like going to
a chinese restaurant here and ordering
sweet and sour chicken right yeah
because that's not even chinese food
right
i think it's all bastardized versions of
the food that would be palatable to the
people who want to consume it yeah yeah
but surely it's wrong with that like you
teleported any american to like shinjin
china and they went to like a local
eatery they'd be lost oh yeah
i like kung pao chicken like what's
going on here
man panda express looks different
does express goods uh
i mean it hits it hits right
yeah it's i think you're gonna be in the
right move for pandarus yeah yeah
because sometimes i've been what is the
right mood
it's the mood of [ __ ] there's nothing
else open
in the mood
the mood is i need food and i need it
now i see some food
but it's just a bodily necessity i don't
want to like chow down on a burger or
like a pizza or like anything like
greasy i just want like something and
you go to panda express for a non-greasy
food well i've only been like twice so
you know that says a lot i will say i i
do think sometimes the bastardization of
food is good
well yeah like i'm not going to say no
no
yeah amazing yeah i'm not going to say
no to a california role like that
it's an innovation in a way i don't
think that's like the best ideas
bastardization of food though right
some people would say it is like i think
there's an argument we made i mean i i
think the best argument i've heard is i
was like i can't remember like what chef
i was like watching but i know i do
believe you can cook food from any
culture that you want to and no no
recipes sacred the only the only time it
is actually offensive is just if it
tastes bad right
yeah i agree you know what but i do
think there are people who would be
upset if you called a dish like what
it's called natively like if you called
it sushi but it was like some
amalgamation of fish in different things
that taste good but it's like you can't
call that sushi yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
you know i do get that where i've seen
like some people try to cook thai dishes
and like i've seen like i've seen some
uh there was this like reality tv show
on netflix where people from the uk
would try to like make their own
restaurants and pitch it like kind of
like uh
kind of like uh nightmares sorry not
kitchen no kitchen nightmares like shark
tank like shop
meals
food i remember these two british blokes
tried to like pitch like opening a thai
restaurant in manchester
and so and so they were going about
their backstory and they were like yeah
you know i we firmly believe that you
know you don't as long as you understand
the culture and you understand the
recipes and everything that no recipe is
sacred and i was like yeah i agree with
that you know i'm not gonna get
patriotic to my own country just because
someone else wants to cook it yeah and
then they was talking about their
experience cooking thai dishes and they
were like yeah we've been to like
thailand for like two months and uh did
like a boot camp and that was it and i
was like
are you [ __ ] kidding me
that's like that's like the backstory of
the two guys who uh started outback
steakhouse not really they'd never been
to australia
supposedly and it's an australian
restaurant so because like i remember
the first time i went to an outback
steakhouse was on australia day god
forbid in japan of all places and my
friend was like yeah there's no bug
steakhouse right there we should we
should celebrate australia what a crazy
mashup of cultures to be eating in an
outback steakhouse an american-made
australian restaurant in japan
presumably japanese chefs as well yeah
and i walk and i've never been to an
outback steakhouse i was like oh let's
go in it's it's supposedly australian
right yeah and immediately like my eyes
has glazed over from all the [ __ ]
boomerangs on the walls and like the
disney dudes everywhere i looked
and i had fosters there i did i tried
fosters for the first time oh gosh in
japan yeah it tastes like awesome it's
awful it's [ __ ] horrible i'm like no
wonder they don't sell that in australia
yeah fosus has a single-handedly ruined
australian spear reputation yes i mean
australian beer still sucks ass but like
it's like fosters is yeah there's a
reason why they don't sell in australia
no one would drink that yeah it's like
like in the uk we have uh our local beer
that's mass reduced it's probably
calling and i'm so glad that you can
only get it in the uk or i've only seen
it in the uk because it tastes like piss
right because you had carling right did
you have darling yeah
it was horrible i think it's yeah it's
definitely uk let's have a look before i
think that's every country though like
we always release our worst product but
it's maybe the most palatable because
it's just water and it gets you pissed
drunk quick what would you say is the
worst american you're gonna say it's bud
is it canadian
no [ __ ] way is it canadian uh damn it
was founded in 1840 by thomas carling at
london and upper canada uh in 1952
carling oh yeah there's a london in
canada that's right london
oh you thought it was
weirdly enough it's it's a canadian
company but they only sold it in uh in
the uk it was first sold in the uk
is it only sold in the uk i don't know
so it's a uk beverage made by canadian
man
so much good beer though that isn't
carly yeah we do we do we just i um most
of them actually comes from the north
actually you you guys you guys make
goodreads
i'll give you guys there's a w here
there's a w
whales whales whales that's how you sell
whales we have good beer
it's very affordable as well it's like
half the price of london yeah massage
third the third time the price yeah what
do you think is the worst
us beer that you guys export a lot it's
all [ __ ] i mean it's like if you have
bud light you have natty light which is
terrible
do you secretly love budweiser oh we did
a beer tasting stream once uh a blind
beer tasting stream from like beers from
all over the world yeah and we thought
budweiser was like a german
like budweiser like like normal
budweiser i mean that's better that's a
full-bodied
it certainly doesn't make you look like
you have great tastes yeah exactly
because especially we were like drinking
and we're all like yeah german beer
definitely german beer is there a big
drinking culture in new hampshire
uh no big fentanyl culture though they
do a lot of fentanyl what's that that's
the like the it's the most lethal drug
in the world
yeah it's like what they
tie in with heroin and that's how people
die
huge opioid crisis in new hampshire is
it actually yeah they're bored they're
bored it's i mean it's less people in
new hampshire than like phoenix arizona
it's like one million maybe
you must be bored if you like can't even
like even turn to alcoholism you're like
no no i need something harder than
alcohol yeah we need to go further than
beyond yeah the american medical system
has failed america you know
but it's it's cool drugs man you're
losers
well you know new hampshire state motto
no what is it live free or die oh is
that actually yeah it's badass
and they'll inject that into their veins
is that what they say right before they
do the job at least they were free
can't take that away from them
to my fellow new hampshire rights
i thought the east coast had a a good
drinking culture i thought they were
they were like all about drinking beer
and i think like boston boston's i mean
in general in the states they've relaxed
microbrewery laws so like you know
there's insane beer culture if you're
really into it like yeah i guess boston
makes sense because every second
bostonian is like yes i'm irish yeah
yeah they're they all really yeah that
is my biggest pet peeve of americans is
claiming like a european culture when
it's like you have zero attachment
outside of you took a 23 in me or your
parents told you like yeah we're irish i
think yeah that's that's my favorite
copium where i'm like oh so where's your
family from and they're like oh i'm like
1 16th irish
116th i'm like that doesn't count why do
they try and hold on to that like why is
that something they they gravitate to
try and label them connor it's not that
cool to be just american these days
i don't know if you've kept up
that's badass like why why do people
still try and do it i think it like it
also ties into things that's how it
comes up it'll be like oh i can drink
all night i'm 15 irish
i don't think alcoholism just goes
through gymnastics no and of course it
doesn't but then it'll be like you know
be like oh i can't be in the sun too
long i'm 20 polish so like they just
have that and that's like they'll spout
their one fact it's just like an rpg
skill tree yeah i've spent too much into
strength i can't i can't do the agility
exactly but it's like your starting
stats and it's like it doesn't matter
you could spec anything you wanted as
well
yeah yeah like i'm like i'm like
southeast asian full-blooded southeast
asian i cannot [ __ ] handle the heat
at all yeah so obviously it's got
nothing to do with my genetics and
everything to do with my [ __ ]
upbringing right yeah yeah or [ __ ]
what is what is your
ethnicity background so like culturally
i'm very french
five percent irish
welsh baby uh i'm mostly uh my dad's
side is like all swedish and then my
mom's side's all spanish and they both
immigrated to america from there oh but
my mom first generation yeah i'm first
shot i'm the only person in my family
tree ever born in america wow but now
i'm hard-blooded murk and
through and through
my my blood's red white and blue
uh
but yeah everyone else like mostly
france and sweden's where they all live
now
and have you seen like that uh your
family in europe and stuff like that
yeah we used to go every summer so i
would spend like like a month in europe
and i was always like a pissy bratty kid
because i'd be like i want to be in
america and get a cake for my birthday
and hang out with my soccer friends and
i'd be like no you have to go on a like
a multi week where's my sunny d
you guys go to france and sweden and
experience cultures and i was like
and i was such a brat i regret it
because i got we would go to france and
it'd be like like near nice like
beautiful
and and i'd be in the like my uncle's
house just watching naruto like
mainlining filler episodes and then
they'd be like oh come out let's go to
like the beach like pellevester floats
and i was like
yeah we spoke about this
i had the same thing my parents took me
all around yeah i want to play games i
hated that they took me around and now i
kind of regret it but when i was a kid i
was like all i want to do is play
pokemon fire red like leave me alone
mine was pokemon ruby and watch naruto
and outside of that piss off and i don't
want to speak this stupid language speak
english to me
i'd like go around hunting for wi-fi
like my whole thing is the whole trip i
would just try and find wi-fi yeah that
would literally be it it was so hard
back then too oh yeah because there
wasn't like a starbucks or mcdonald's
that has free wi-fi for everyone yeah
yeah it was hard and then you'd have to
go and ask the staff really awkwardly
and they'd be like oh
we're in france we don't want to give
you anything yeah i would just like
stock up on games on like my game boy
and just like bring like a [ __ ]
rucksack full of game cartridges so i
was never bored
you know you're trying to you're trying
to date a little bit you're trying to
message trying to keep up you know and i
just couldn't because
that's that's what you think i tried to
i was married to pokemon
the week before i was supposed to go to
france i got a call after school had
ended from this girl and and she her
name was alexis and she was like hey uh
racelyn which is another girl from my
class racelyn wants to date you and i
was like super uncomfortable and i'd
never like done that before so i was
like uh
i'm going to france
and she's like well yeah what like
she wants to like date you and like go
like you can date when you come back
yeah and i was like
oh no i got to go to france
and i kept mainlining that and that's
how i got out of it that next year
raceland got expelled permanently
because she showed up to school with a
bunch of knives she was very edgy oh wow
she used to show up with like about the
golf guild championship she was goth
girl gf she showed up powdered sugar be
like it's cocaine
and then she showed up with knives until
she got expelled but then i think she
actually became edgy because she
tattooed 5150 on her neck yeah which is
the cop signal for like crazy person on
the loose
and she got it just big tattooed so i
could have dated her
what is helpful but i went to france i
could have had the ghost because
so like
why smash what got you into that
oh like super smash bros yeah you
because you you're like what's the
matter
in general
everything philosopher's
how did that get in uh smash bros was
because smash four came out and i wanted
to be better than my friends no always
the third one oh
it goes yeah ultimate
you make me so disappointed it's the one
for wii u
it's literally called for it's called
smash 4 wii u
smash 4 smash 4 wii u why can't you just
say which one it is why did you say
number he did he said smash 4 i'm
explaining why you're wrong i'm sorry i
don't know the chronological order of
all the smash games it's called smash 4
though it's not like it was called like
smash 4 fight fight fight smash wii u
just say smash wheels right now
he's a real snap creator clash 2 me
versus you
i got into it because smash 4 for the
wii u in 3ds that came out in 2016 came
out and i uh and i was the worst in my
friend group
and i was always the worst of my friend
group and so i wanted to be better than
them because i went to college and i was
like i'll come back and i'll beat their
ass like an anime yeah so i went through
a training arc and i watched a bunch of
videos online of j-tales and that's
where i found like retro gaijin and i'd
watch his streams to get better and i
got a lot better and i even showed up to
like some events uh and i came back and
i
pummeled them just whooped their asses
which i found out it turns out it's not
that fun i was gonna say yeah when
you're way better than your friends they
don't want to play with you because they
keep losing and it's sad so the
gratification i had of being better was
replaced by sorrow of not being able to
play with them because they didn't want
to play with me anymore suffering from
success
this is just one punch man man yeah
right yeah
it was too easy yeah no opponents for me
uh well then i found out though there
was a competitive scene because when
what happens is you beat your friends
you're like i'm goaded i'm the guy i'm
god like i want to play someone better
and you go to all the locals and you're
like oh wait
i'm actually like level three yeah and
i'm all the way down here did you just
get stomped the first local you went to
first local for smash four i did okay
but i watched the i don't know if you've
heard of this the smash documentary yeah
yeah yeah
have you guys seen it a four-hour one
yeah yeah so i watched that and i was
like i'm playing the wrong game
and i switched to melee and then i was
like i was all the way down here i was
terrible because they have like decades
yeah yeah yeah
put into it and people have trained for
a long time and i found out that the the
college i went to there's a hundred man
locals it was like free to play no prize
entry uh and no money for you winning
but they just play for the fun of it
right and uh and a hundred people show
up and i wanted to get better so i was
trying to go through a training arc so i
did this thing one time that i saw in
the documentary
where i challenged a bunch of guys who
were in a clan to a money match
yeah they were called uh they were
called [ __ ] lot
and that was their clan name and i
challenged each and every one of them to
a money match and they just ran a train
on me oh yeah just one by one dusting me
taking ten dollars from me until one guy
pulled out donkey kong which is like one
of the worst characters and he beat my
ass with donkey kong which is never
supposed to be jigglypuff and i was like
demoralized from it uh
but that's it it also made me addicted
so i just played like every day for like
three years from then right damn did you
ever get any good
i i mean about it now i was like all
right i was
i beat like a couple notable people like
chilling dudes mario
which is not his main character
and i got top eight at a charity
tournament once pretty yeah pretty good
not bad
not bad uh but i was all right i i never
i switched pretty quickly to commentary
because like wait i don't have to try
and i can make fart jokes and
you get more twitter followers you get
more stage time yeah that's cool oh do
you ever want to get like did you ever
want to pursue it further or get even
better or are you just like nah i've
reached my ceiling do you ever have this
thing where you really want to be good
at something but then you think about
being good at it and you feel the
gratification of thinking about being
good
i did that
i i i thought about that sounds so sad
yeah so you're just sitting there being
like i could be really gratification
feeling good without doing it and it's
like it's like a micro hit
but it is it is it is instant as opposed
to like the literal five years of work
you would need to put in to get the true
satisfaction
so you gained that fake serotonin yeah
you are getting that real serotonin
dosing on happiness
every morning
it's good it's like it's like if you
find a sick anime and you're like [ __ ]
this is the greatest anime and you want
to find something else like it but you
just never try to find something else
like it you're just like no i'm good i
just re-watch one piece for like five
minutes yeah literally and i'll just
re-watch this in my mind and i'll be the
best in my mind except it never happens
right yeah but it's okay
in my mind i'm sick
so when did you start watching
anime happened well i applied for so i
worked at apple
uh okay which i i was um they had a
college program and i would do tech
support which was my numbing because i
would talk to 60 year old people on how
to reset their iphone
and and i was good at it too i was like
top ten at one point out of like two
thousand in the college program old
people
yeah cause like they would they would
they would they have every single metric
on her yeah so it's like how long were
you on the call were they was it a
successful call did they give you a
positive review how quickly did you pick
up a call after hanging up that call
because you answered back in the queue
like was your downtime good and so they
tracked all of this and like i had a six
month period where i was like
just going off trying to do really well
yeah uh but after two and a half years
it was like it was great for two and a
half years yeah oh my gosh
so i would watch anime on the side
and uh and i did it because um
oh this is so cringe i even hate talking
about this
all right
so i usually what happens is you go to
college in a different state or
somewhere else in a different city and
you come back home for the summer yeah
one summer i was like no
sigma
i'm gonna stay in this town because i
have the dorm anyway yeah and i'm gonna
work on self-improvement okay and i made
a youtube channel called
self-improvement
and every day
i would i would work on fitness i would
work on learning a new language
and i would work on playing the piano
okay and by the end of the summer i
would like
have my level up moment yeah right and i
would record myself
running at like 9 00 p.m in 95 degree
weather in phoenix arizona and then just
take a picture of myself shirtless like
fully relaxed and i just i imagined a
time lapse through all of this right and
i would like practice a piano and i'd be
like ichi knee song
and and i and i uploaded like maybe two
of these right uh and i recorded intros
on like rooftop parking lots
uh again i'd never done youtube to this
point really right
and i got a call from my mom she's like
saw your youtube channel because
unbeknownst to me it had been
cross-posted to my google plus account
which she had access to because she knew
my email yeah and this was like my one
viewer it was my mom
and i was mortified and i stopped it
that day she said she was like she was
like so you're doing some fitness stuff
huh
she didn't really get it she's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing so your mom
stopped you from doing self-improvement
i was embarrassed and i didn't want my
my mom to be my only viewer watching me
run sure who knows what you could have
been right now you could have been
teaching a self-help
class and i'd probably be on the jet
program playing subpar piano running
around the streets of tokyo shirtless i
i'm happy with where it ended up
he reached in here man he like he's he's
mikey like he's like it is ripped he's
like
he's got
feedback to anime
well so then i quit that and instead
what i did is the rest of the summer
watch anime
so wait how did you why why anime you
never watched enemy movies i was i was
like i'm just gonna watch anime i
watched it as a kid growing up i watched
naruto i watched dragon ball z kai and
uh but i never watched anything else i
had like a couple shonen jump
yeah uh but nothing hardcore like one
piece two uh and then when i applied for
the jet program i was like because
that's where i pivoted after the
self-help thing i was like i'll do a jet
program okay my mom won't see that
and i was like okay chris broad videos
and what's a good anime i looked it up
and i was like okay sort out online
oh no it's my first anime it's not a bad
first anime i i do think it's good
flames it's it's good it's such a good
show
i think it's very good at introducing
people to anime i will say that it's a
good game
i mean it is like it it has all the
tropes you will find in anime yeah yeah
it gets you ready for it crossfield of
dreams song is also good the one where
it's like the the field yeah
yeah that opening
and i'm like and it's like spy kids 3d
so it's like i want to be you die in the
game you die in real life
you know and it's a lot of tropes that i
know and i was like i'm all on board up
until the main villain was holding the
like main protagonist girl and like like
sexually assaulting her oh yeah that's
interesting
i was like whoa which time yeah which
yeah yeah happens off the inside
unfortunately yeah it's every awkward
and then season two
like sisters like oni-chan i'm like whoa
and then and then i'm actually your
cousin
i was like maybe i should find a new man
i i stuck it out all the way through the
gun series too oh gun gale yeah yeah i
gave it a good i watched all the guys
shot online as i like to call it yeah
literally just ass shots and then
shaking violently when the sniper goes
yeah yeah apparently it gets better no
like recently it's gotten better it does
no it does no i've heard i've heard it's
good now okay like
as much as like clown on sword arts
online it's just kind of like my junk
food i've actually i realized this
recently i've watched every
anime of sword art online that's been
produced so far really yeah i don't know
why how or why i did this to myself but
i did and the latest season alicization
i i generally think is a lot of fun
would i call it good
i don't know it's kind of like fun in
american culture a lot of the times
people have like a sitcom that they just
watch on repeat it's like their comfort
sitcom and it's it's well it's like it's
friends it's hemium it's big bang theory
if you have no taste and it's just their
show and like that's what sort of it is
you know it's just easy
it doesn't surprise you too much
is the big bang theory of anime yeah
honestly
honestly
then what did you watch well then i
wanted to be cultured right so i looked
up what the best anime were okay and i
tried to watch those okay so like full
metal alchemist brotherhood right
couldn't get through it
i i couldn't get through it did you
eventually get through it no so long
uh hunter hunter what
it was so long connor
64 episodes yeah but by episode like 35
it's mostly like recap and talking and
and fighting brotherhood yeah
brotherhood why did we watch the same
show it's so slow it's a lot of
recapping it's a lot of it's not it's
not well-paced i i haven't seen in a
long time so i can't you are the only
person i've ever met who has started
brotherhood and hasn't finished that's
that's like blasphemous you know what's
[ __ ] up too i love silver spoon
what's [ __ ] up about where the [ __ ]
did that come from that's a good show
same director
yeah and it but it's like nothing to do
with it's clearly the less popular of
the shows that she's made nobody talks
about civil spoon yeah i love
silversmith though
yeah to be fair your favorite anime uh
that you told me about your thing was a
huge surprise like the fact that your
favorite anime is welcome to the nhk
yeah it says like already a lot
yeah because what i did is like you go
through the annie list like top hundred
yeah and like i gave at least every big
show like an episode or two right and
and i was either like okay i don't vibe
with this i don't [ __ ] with this and i
don't subscribe to the
dude you just gotta watch chill episode
77. i agree i agree and i don't i don't
buy that it's like okay if it hasn't
pulled out every one piece fan right
yeah
it's like if i haven't if i haven't like
gotten into it then i my time is more
valuable than subscribing to 70 episodes
to enjoy something i can just enjoy
something off episode one and that's
great yeah of course uh and so i try
them all and then you do what you
normally do which is ask other people
and so i asked will neff do you guys
know will neff no he's like another
streamer i do the name sounds familiar
yeah he's a he's a pretty successful
streamer he's a super sweet guy and like
one of the greatest entertainers i think
in the space
uh and he's a huge weeb right right and
he's an older guy and he's like yeah you
got to watch welcome to the nhk man like
it's a little horny but it's like it's
perfect it's like you're ever feeling
lonely i'm like
that's all my boxes
and i watched it and it's so good it's
very yeah it's it's incredible i haven't
actually watched that one really i've
been putting it off
it is i think like
the worst first anime if you've never
watched it but i think you need to be in
the right headspace to watch it
you know that's actually from welcome to
the nhk
um but yeah it's like
very real depressingly real a lot of
times
um so it's not something you watch to be
happy it's like something you watch to
just feel i don't know i don't know what
the right word it's like obviously
like it's a great show and it's like you
learn a lot from it and it's very real
but it's not something it's not
entertainment yeah well i think that's
exactly what i i switched because in
senior year of college like this is also
like kind of right when it started and i
was watching anime right my girlfriend
and i broke up because i caught her
cheating on me right and i made a
visceral decision i literally was like i
am going to try to cry more because i'm
not like a guy who cries a lot right
when i watch shows right which is like a
literal shift in how you like try to
process them yeah and so then i like i
tried to do it first but i was like okay
i'll watch your line april
just like dry crying
[Music]
i was like that made me cry but i was
like am i crying because it's like good
and making me feel or is it because it's
emotionally manipulative and they make
you attach to a character and they play
the sad song at the sad time when you're
supposed to cry oh no i totally get what
you mean where there's like two
different types of crying where there
are some shows which you cry you just
you don't even know why you're crying
yeah you feel like a [ __ ] somewhere
in there yeah yeah you feel like a dog
there where like you have like the right
triggers and then it just like triggers
your tears and you're like i don't know
why i'm crying it's just no silver spoon
for me really you're not supposed to cry
at that necessarily but at a certain
point like i was doing the festival and
i was like it's so beautiful
and i was like that's why it was one of
my favorite shows as opposed to like a
show that's like you know the classics
that like you're gonna cry like the like
the cry face like alexander and stuff
like that right we have planned this for
you to tear up yeah which i don't i
think that's that's more bs yeah so
that's why i love welcome to nhk because
it makes you feel so much yeah just like
uh for my lifetime's brotherhood well
towards the end
i am a homunculus i am not
you did not get 30 episodes i did i got
i got all the way to a point where they
were in some like white universe and it
was like blondie with the [ __ ]
alfalfa hair and he was talking to
himself isn't that near the [ __ ] end
it was close that's pretty close what
the [ __ ] i remember and then i was like
no spoilers god hasn't seen it yet
no i've never seen how are you on this
podcast
that's
how are you calling him out for not
watching it when you haven't [ __ ]
finished it because i don't have a
podcast called trash days
in a 15-year career fresh taste i'm not
anime
yeah i mean like uh i mean it's just
like it's just one of those shows where
god has to explain it for the night i
haven't explained it everything i don't
know i don't explain i don't want to
[ __ ] hear it i'm just gonna think of
you less for having seen of all of sword
art online and not
posted about watching every season not
even like people who like sort of online
watch all season four i'm getting like
for mr almost at this point it's just
gonna be like the last anime i ever
watched yeah you're like nine years old
on my death bed i'm gonna be like now
it's the time
to experience brotherhood and then your
soul fades before the final episode i'm
getting 30 episodes
i've never heard of anyone
getting getting halfway through it and
dropping it that is psychotic i think
maybe if i retried it because it was an
early it was an early show like i sucked
through all of them were you killed by
the hype of like hearing about the show
yeah because it was listed as like one
of the best okay yeah it's the goat i
don't think it is i don't think it is
what i don't think it's the i don't
think it's what do you think of some
hyped anime that actually like meets the
hype then or meet the representative
reputation madoka magicka
hell yeah that shows
that it's why are you like that's a good
show it's a great race
i don't think so now good
i've seen the movie soon
promise neverland season one
yeah we don't talk about it we don't
talk about this we don't talk about this
wait there's season two you don't have
to watch it it's fine is it great
nah this is a bit it's just
i stopped watching it but season one i
think is amazing it's like a show that
if i told someone to watch it's like
they'd be like yeah that was great just
death no
fathom code yes [ __ ] it up
why can't you fathom that people [ __ ]
things up all the time because it was
just literally like just follow the
blueprints because literally like the
fourth highest literally just follow
what is happening and then they were
like
like the manga was so successful and the
fan base was so big so that you'd think
there'd be like massive pressure to be
like all right we got to deliver to the
fans and then they're like i know what
they're like a powerpoint
presentation for the last episode
skipped and then everything yeah they
skipped everything yeah i heard they get
the best i skipped the best
if that happened in like the one piece
anime people would like they i think
that they'd be riots in japan i think
people would actually would like quick
jobs they also do the opposite where
they just extend it for 3 000.
why do we have to extend it a billion
times and then why can't you just follow
the manga another time in recap syndrome
if it's the fourth highest selling
market why would the [ __ ] would you not
just stick to the market honestly i i
don't know i don't have an explanation
for you because they [ __ ] killed it
on season one and all they need to do
was just do more of that
and then they just didn't i don't know
maybe they wanted to finish it in two
seasons but i don't know why they would
because it's like the fourth yeah i
don't know i think i think it's always
down to like probably rush timelines and
some person above you who tells you to
do things and you have to do them but i
always just assumed that if you were the
your studio right it must be a [ __ ]
blessing getting a show that you could
make like 10 seasons of because you get
well no because you don't have
guaranteed funding for those seasons i
guess because like then you end up with
situations where it's like you have a
show that's great and then it's never
finished
yeah yeah and then that's like an
equally bad fate to die from yeah what
was the uh what was the first show you
watched where you had that cruel
realization that sometimes
very often anime it just doesn't end or
they just stopped making it or the
mountains i watched um i watched devils
a part-timer oh yeah like five years ago
i was like dude this is hilarious yeah
and i was like season two and then you
find like like the threads being like is
there a season two is there a season two
and i was like no actually there is no
yeah i know i heard it's actually airing
next season i'm hyped on that because
that show is really funny and i like it
a lot yeah i wonder if it'll be as funny
as i remember because i watched it like
five six years also watch it dubbed as
well
dub was really really good for that uh
that series so i don't know if i will it
will watch the same yeah yeah yeah i
feel like when it's such a comedic
timing show having good voice acting in
english definitely helps
i appreciate the jokes more as an
english person yeah i mean i feel like
especially with comedy shows and comedy
anime my favorite comedy anime are all
ones that have amazing dubs because
stalking huh panty stalking using
aunties
no because i generally don't go to anime
for comedy because i think 99 of comedy
animes aren't funny yeah yeah that is
very sure that is true it's rare i find
a good comedy anime yeah a lot of them
are like comedy
like what's the one that everyone talks
about that's been long psyche
is that it
that that show sucked you know one of
the [ __ ] looks like holy just
no that one's fun i think that's pretty
funny it sounds like a ligma though
that's that's like kind of uh how do you
describe sacramento it's more like mr
bean
kind of in a way it's very slapstick oh
it's physical comedy it's yeah very
important it's like if mr bean was a
giga chad right yeah
i would be i would love to see the live
action of mr bean just yoked
isn't that johnny england
yeah yeah
what are some other shows that you like
man
i feel like um
i i had a shounen phase
everyone that and everyone else in the
world i see you were once 14 years old
i loved hunter hunter
yes because that [ __ ] was just it was
just great were you cool to almost long
and you finish on to hunter
name another show where you cry over an
octopus
yeah
one piece yeah you cry over an octopus
in one piece yeah try over a lot in one
piece
there's a lot of things you cry over
okay well i gotta get that
i think uh i think for me it's like
they just they they've mastered the
formula in every shonen it's like they
know the exact moment to play the exact
song that's like the perfect song where
it's like the naruto theme or it's like
the you say run and it's like the
climactic and they just have it it's
like it will never surprise me ever it's
basically the hero's journey retold a
million times yeah but they're good at
it they're very good at it but you know
one thing i miss i've noticed like a lot
of shonen shows are just anime shows
i've been doing this less often recently
which is you know it's the end of the
season and then they play the op and i
i've noticed they stopped doing that and
it was just like yeah it became a trope
but it worked every [ __ ] time right
um like where it's like they and they
lift off in a sunset and then you know
season two is coming or something yeah
yeah yeah yeah i'm just like i wish they
brought that back and they're all laughs
the 80s freeze frame right yeah it is
it's that yeah i think it's a bit corny
and what happens is it it's too corny
and then it goes out of style and then
it comes back in right yeah yeah
cycles yeah because like i remember
because hunter hunter had like the same
op throughout it's every season that
gets me hyped
yo he got you so hyped now and and now
every different season has a different
opening i'm like come on bring back
hunter hunter man that yeah that note
only needed one opening departure
isn't it crazy because like attack on
titan's like 10 openings yeah that's
[ __ ] they're good
rumbling is awesome
i like that they try new ones because i
feel like they come out with some
bangers well i feel like i feel like
attack on titan i can understand it
because every season has such a
different vibe to it like season one and
season four have like nothing in common
with it but you know i the one thing i
do like about it when they have the same
opening is that it it's you recognize it
so much familiarity don't you you play
an op and you're like i don't know i
don't know what this is it's like oh
it's a tackle titan season three uh
opening one you're like what the [ __ ]
i had no [ __ ] idea i i like listen to
this i i have that problem watching
guinta because there's like literally 20
openings in game time they're all
bangers but it's like you know you want
that one where you're just like oh yeah
i remember that but imagine naruto only
had one
they have the best intros there's so
many i guess sorry goated interest
that's true that's true it's true but
like how many do you remember out of
like the millions that they've had i
only
which is like arguably the best one i
think i remember the third one three
blueberries did you ever watch uh
the monogatari series you'd love that
shirt would he i don't know so he he
likes nhk no he would not he'd get to
the toothbrush scene he'd be like what
the [ __ ] is this that's some out of
pocket [ __ ] yeah what happens
it's some horny [ __ ] yeah what happened
it's a [ __ ] weird show if if you
thought the uh
the wait what was the first show you
watched online with the guy
holding onto the girl was a [ __ ]
weird you're probably even more weirded
out by the stuff i mean that was early
on like yeah there's weirder [ __ ] and
like eventually what happens it's like
it's like when you're a kid you see live
league footage you become desensitized
to the internet anime fans become
desensitized to like what is weird
there's a very famous scene where the
guy's sister yeah sister is brushing his
teeth and it's like animated like porn
and it's they're all like moaning and
[ __ ] and like oh while brushing yeah
like what is the brushing so good yeah
it's like food wars eating it's like no
brushing honestly honestly like it's
[ __ ] awesome honestly i i'm going to
defend this because it's a really really
weird because you were because it's a
brother and sister no no okay
genuinely
i wish hentai was this well directed
it's such a well [ __ ] directed scene
to be like okay how can we make tooth
brushing really uncomfortable and really
weird and yeah it's [ __ ] weird and
it's horny as [ __ ] but like is that what
opened like your chakras to brother
sister kind of i don't think i i don't
know
that was oriented but you must have
watched back one of the guys three first
right i watched batman got three first
but it's not even in pokemon go it's in
season two yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
don't know like welcome on a guthrie was
just it's a weird show in general it's
got like very weird like directing
choices it's one of my favorites really
yeah yeah it's like it's it's a joey
show because it's [ __ ] like it's
arthousy it's like it's like nothing
[ __ ] makes sense and then everyone's
like that's the point and it's like yeah
but it does make sense is the thing
do you think end of evangelion's like
that
ah that's like way too mainstream now i
think
but it also doesn't make that much
[ __ ] sense no
i i'm i think evangelion is kind of mid
uh i think it's kind of way over hyped
and it was just like it just happened to
be there the right time so it kind of
caught massive popularity because of
that yeah i ran high so people think i'm
cool and it was doing something like
doing something unique
yeah no [ __ ] but i'm not even
entertaining that could that call it
true i do that yeah i was like yeah i
love that show that's great but i when i
think back on it i was like i don't like
it like we should have it like
did you watch evangelion were you like
this is insane i was just kind of like
okay i mean i think i don't know if it's
because i've watched shows that have
come out after but maybe if i was there
at the time i could see why it would
blow the [ __ ] up and be such a big deal
but now it doesn't feel that special
yeah i mean ava for me like ava's like
one of my favorite shows of all time i
[ __ ] hated it the first time i
watched it yeah like i i legitimately i
legitimately thought it was like the
most overrated piece of [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my life and it was just i don't
know it's it's very it's it is a
pretentious show
it's a [ __ ] pretentious show because
i only liked it because i was [ __ ]
depressed one time i watched it and i'm
like [ __ ] hell there's someone who
gets me because that's that's just
that's just av it's just like me for
real yeah yeah yeah that's just like the
whole struggling with relationships and
uh growing up and struggling being a
teen i yeah i just like cause i watched
boca rano before it i thought boca rano
handled it like way better yeah but i'm
sure poker hunter took notes from
evangelion yeah there it did yeah but
like because the mech fighting in book
riot was dog [ __ ] this episode is
sponsored by manscaped gentlemen it is
smooth sack summer
joy what is smooth sack summer tell me
more when you're playing out in the hot
summer sun especially when you're in
japan your balls are going to get a
little bit musky
so it's best gentlemen you trim down
there make it a little bit nicer that
your balls can actually breathe and
thankfully manscaped is here to help you
gentlemen achieve that goal okay and
just for you guys you can dive head
first into smooth sack summer by going
to manscape.com for 20 off plus free
shipping without code trash taste
manscape performance package 4.0 has
everything you need to prepare for that
summer bod inside the package you'll
find the lawnmower 4.0 weed whacker ear
and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop reviver toner
performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold all your goodies my balls
are excited the razors will devour your
strongest pubes literally just eat them
up like
[Music]
that sounds delicious gang so if that
entices your nut sack then you can check
out manscape by clicking the link
description below and you can get 20 off
plus free shipping using our code trash
taste at manscape.com that's 20 off plus
free shipping with the code trash taste
back to the episode some guy they're in
a cave when there's like 10 of them on a
school trip is like hey you want to play
a game
and then they got they're like the kids
are like well [ __ ] you i want to play a
game like and so he's like oh go on this
thing and then he teleports them to a
mac and then he's like all right who
wants to pilot the mac first and then
some kid's like yo [ __ ] you i want to
pile up the mac kid parts the mech and
he's like right now there is another mac
that is invading your world if you don't
kill the smack your your world gets
destroyed and then i was like oh okay so
then the kid takes it beats the mech and
i was like yeah
and the episode ends and the kid just
dies
why because anyone who's a one-time use
yeah and it's all like 12 13 year old 16
year old kids and does using him as
fodder yeah so it's like a darker
ender's game yeah but it's like it's not
it's like
it's not like it's kind of like a horror
thing where it's like whoa it's like a
death game it's like they have to save
the world and they have to die to do it
it's like a psychological but they don't
know they all know wait they didn't know
though they didn't know initially and
they see the kid they didn't know until
the first kid died and then and then
someone actually and then the guy was
like oh [ __ ] what happened to the kid
yeah that wasn't supposed to happen
like these kids i guess it's gonna
happen forever though and basically it's
already running it's already right they
don't know who's uh who's turn's next um
so all the kids are just kind of like
and you don't know when you're gonna get
summoned right so all the kids are just
kind of dealing with their mortality do
they know they're gonna win uh they
don't know they're gonna win
like that would be the more stressful
yeah
i feel like this was pretty
irresponsible
of course it is but it's an amazing
thing you should train the kids a little
more and some of the kids deal with like
this whole mortality and having to pile
up this mac and it's so nuanced it's so
good
such a good opening and like i just felt
like it it offered so much more in that
like kind of dealing with it and it had
in my mind i felt like it did it better
than evangelion no because like i i
think i think it's entirely different
from what i felt from ava right because
eve like i i look at boca raton i'm like
this is a really really good exploration
into like characters and how they deal
with mortality and all that [ __ ] but
then like you look at the last two
episodes of ava and it's just like it's
just a [ __ ] person laying themselves
bare they don't even give a [ __ ] if
they're making sense because it's making
no [ __ ] sense at all but like if
you've been in that same headspace
there's like a connection there that is
hard to communicate because it's not
really telling a story it's just a guy
just being like i'm [ __ ] depressed
and i just want to put something out
it's just like an overflow of emotion
yeah yeah that's what that's what i
think is unique about ava where i don't
even think like if you say ava's a [ __ ]
story i'm gonna agree with you it's it's
it's there are like so many [ __ ] plot
holes and [ __ ] that doesn't get
explained i'm not saying it's bad it's
just i i i don't think it's as uh good
as it's hyped up to be i don't know yeah
that's easy to say yeah only bold takes
heroes
this this thing actually might not be
that good well you know like you know
not not everything that is extremely
influential is necessarily going to
stand the test
i mean jojo has a lot of dog [ __ ] stuff
in it like it's a i love jojo to death
there's also a lot of influential [ __ ]
that you can understand and believe
that's influential but you don't care
about oh yeah yeah movies like i've
never seen citizen kane it seems boring
as hell
three hours
casablanca no shot yeah
get some color in there
four by three yeah
grow up this is not smash 64.
a lot of filler man
film film is like three and a half hours
or some [ __ ] bruh
got some of that damage is like the
[ __ ] schneider cup that's crazy right
any controversial or uh un you know
unpopular opinions of anime i you got
mad at me five seconds ago
conversation yeah uh you okay do you do
this this is a a quick aside okay but
okay i will i will consume an anime yeah
yeah and depending on if it's a good
ending i will feel emotion and i'll mull
over the thoughts for like a day yeah
and then the next day i'm like googling
like okay what do people think about the
show do people like the show
and like i'll look up all that [ __ ] and
then i'll like add outside knowledge my
own thoughts and i'll try to form my
opinion on it is that how you guys do it
or do you just have your own thoughts i
used to
do that and then i had to stop myself so
now when i watch things i do not look at
reviews before
before and after really i don't want to
know sometimes i'll go i'll have a look
and i'm curious because like i'll be
like um because sometimes it's always
when i think something is bad but i'm
not sure i'm like this is bad i think
and i
feel like people might like it so i go
and look just to confirm but i don't
read reviews i never read reviews
do you do you think that's because it'll
like sully what your thought of it is
definitely i feel like there's
you know when you watch like explainer
videos and they explain more of the
thing to you and you're like oh that's
so big brain like i i watch dune and i
love dune but when i watched a bunch of
explainer videos i was like oh i think i
like dune more yeah then i'm like i've
watched an hour and a half video about
dude and i'm like is that i'm like is is
that do i need that to enjoy it like if
i didn't watch that would i like dune as
much and it's kind of like this weird
thing of like how much do you actually
enjoy something if you everything has to
be explained to you and bogged down and
reviews have to be explained to you and
well maybe it's not necessarily like new
information there yeah but rather
something that maybe you thought
subconsciously which is now actually
being said to you to make you realize
like oh okay i always thought maybe that
element might have been good but now
that i'm keep getting explained yeah now
i can control my suspicions yeah i mean
like i find you know as the guy who
finished like all the [ __ ] sword art
online yeah you know i've gone to a
point with anime where you you watch you
watch anime and you look you you see the
good [ __ ] and you're like damn that's
the good [ __ ] you know i want to find
more of that and then you kind of
realize that
you have taste right and so you have
things that you like about shows and
things that you don't like about shows
and just because some of the elements
about why people are playing are
praising a show in like all the good
shows are presents
that maybe it still doesn't appeal to
you so you you kind of like you kind of
like shave off all the all the fat to
only like the core elements that you do
like you know even that even if that's a
very very niche thing um so you get to a
point where i can tell why i like a show
even if other people won't like that
show like i can say why i would like
watched all the sword art online even
though a lot of people clown and sword
art online i can i can you recognize the
[ __ ] things about the show and you just
kind of learn to ignore it at the end of
the day i like doing it because it it
kind of feels to me like like you can
enjoy a sports game yeah and like you
can watch basketball you'd be like oh
dunk is cool he jumped high yeah but if
you are sitting next to michael jordan
while watching the game like his level
of insight would be like okay you are
you are not seeing the things the way
i'm seeing them yeah yeah and i i know
that my lens is probably like very
narrow in what i'm seeing in that goes
for like shows movies whatever
so that's why i like to like i watched
tom popo i think i told you guys about
which is like the japanese 80s movie
yeah um and you know i was like uh this
movie is the only movie made in the 80s
yeah only
it was a tough decade is what it is
there was a recession
uh the 80s there were the economic
bubbles first time
somewhere else there was a recession
sri lanka was going through it
when is this like a going through that's
true
oh god oh yeah but i was watching it and
and i was like okay i left and i was
like i thought this was great i liked it
but then i like i looked up like little
things about it and i was like yeah it
was actually also a direct contrast to
like western american movies and like
old-fashioned spaghetti westerns and it
was like they called it like a like a
ramen western i was like oh [ __ ] and
then like i could think about it in that
lens and i feel like if i were to
re-watch it i would like have new
appreciation yeah i mean i feel like
stuff like that where you discover
things that you can make that make you
appreciate a certain show more yeah that
that happens like a lot actually but
like in terms of like reading thinking a
show is good and reading reviews and
you're just like my opinion was wrong
this show is actually bad
you know i love it when there's like you
know you you can re-watch a movie and
there's those really cool things that
you missed yeah
but i still think and and fully believe
that a a movie or a tv show on your
first watch should still have everything
for you that you can enjoy yeah if it
doesn't do that it requires someone to
sit you down and be like no no because
let me explain this to you let me
explain i'm like then it's failed yeah
but if i can go back and do the second
time and watch it and i can appreciate
all that amazing yeah like the only time
it ever really happens to me where i
change my opinion instantly is only like
when i'm [ __ ] watching like
masterchef or something you know where
they bring out a dish i'm like that dish
looks delicious and then gordon says
it's disgusting
it looks horrible
i'm with you gordo
you're so right daddy
when they bring out too much food and
i'm like [ __ ] you that's so much bang
for your buck he's like why is there so
much food it's disgusting oh god yeah
it's like yeah with children dude
[ __ ] up i was talking to mr beast
about that because he hung out with
gordon castro
you've heard of him i was a private jet
you know
uh and uh and he was like yeah he's he's
just really serious about his food like
you he because he would he'd be all
jokey and fun because obviously like his
willy wonka [ __ ] was like
not real cooking yeah yeah but when he
ate the food he like took it so
seriously and would retort like very
seriously and like meanly but it's just
because he loves food so much yeah i was
like it's crazy to love something and be
that knowledgeable about it imagine
having like you know gordon ramsay flies
out to you and he's like oh yeah we'll
go for food just pick a restaurant
you're like oh [ __ ]
don't you pick up pick a restaurant you
gotta pick a restaurant it must be awful
dude you want to hear something crazy i
think this will be fine because it'll be
released by the time this is out but
mr beast was doing a no eating for 30
day challenge yeah which which he told
me about on stream before yeah which is
incredibly hard yeah i think i lost
maybe five yeah you know five i could i
could do like one
you could do more than a day one hour
i've been in america too long to do this
you did less an hour in this setting and
then i
uh he lasted so uh mr beast goes for
like quite a while yeah the reason he
cracked is because gordon ramsay cooked
him a meal
and gordon ramsay's like yeah part of
the video was that just unintentionally
it was unintentional because he was
filming willy wonka and then gordon for
his own youtube was like i'll cook you
like this egg meal and he cooks it up
and jimmy's like oh i can't eat and
grown's like well you're gonna have my
meal
and like imagine not eating for like two
weeks and then gordon ramsay is there
how to break him out the most succulent
meal
that is like your anime waifu coming to
life on your nofap challenge
like second to last day of no not
november
yeah okay okay your balls just exploded
you come on site
speaking of which do you watch hentai
not often i used to do you have like
favorites in high school i would just
mainline [ __ ] one piece naruto hentai
oh just they didn't even animate it it
was just pictures no it's just pictures
yeah yeah well because i'm the reader
he's the portrait person
i would watch porn on my psp
which couldn't load
get the videos out yeah and it couldn't
load my brother's videos 10p i'd be like
this that'd be on my watch pixel going
another pixel so i would just watch i
would look at pictures
and uh and pictures of like porn
pictures are like they're really
aggressive oh yeah yeah like porn like
irl porn shoots it's like it's like a
lot
come everywhere and i was like like i'm
a kid i'm like
too much for me
yeah that's when i was i'm in high
school 14 15.
and uh and i'd go on benders too
like marathon jerk off days
and so
to the psp to the
arc ps4 yeah i i nutted every day for a
year straight i would just try to go for
my record
it's like a new mr b dude it was like
18.
in one day in one day and by the end of
it it's just going to cop it bro my
dick's just going
it just dust flies out do 18 in one day
i'm doing 18 in one day you didn't know
i can do eighteen and one i believe
that's not even i would wake up i would
do a few i would a few i would do a few
what you can't back-to-back yeah i can
cover a lethal weapon drake 96-97 i was
i was in that [ __ ] connor this is back
this is like peak balls drop you are
nothing but a horny child i i mean i've
been horny
18 times a day 18 is
you could imagine doing like five or six
five is the most i've done is eight yes
i think i was doing that and that's like
more casual like oh i'm just that's more
casual
[ __ ] this is like this was like a goal
this was a goal this is what this is why
smash players smell so [ __ ] bad this
is unrelated because they would do that
and then rock up to the invitation i
can't wait for you to have fun at anime
it's going to smell amazing isn't it
you're coming yeah for like 18 times
the expo
uh yeah so i was i was going for a
record yeah okay look maybe what purpose
like just because i wanted to see what i
could do i wanted to go further than
beyond come on okay and uh limit testing
his own dick so
no hentai was helping you yes yeah yeah
which characters
uh dude
i could see
[Music]
[Music]
she was one of the senseis
she was dating the guy with the the
blades oh
the one who into like older ones yeah
she's in the older one no you like
mouse
yeah i was in a mills i think who isn't
that but i mean she's not a milf because
she's still like she's like a 25 year
old yeah she's an older older adult to a
15 year old is that a milk
it's not a truth like i think a true
milf i would never
true
like a true mother i would be like oh
that is that is something what did
marlene say to you when you first no is
it you no no no no it's prozy oh yeah
yeah well what happened personally
rocked out within five minutes madeline
is like uh but you know like 16 year
olds can be moms right
that's the intro
okay that's what she said keep it casual
around yeah yeah
wait so are you watching you don't watch
stuff anymore no no
no
yeah yeah where'd you find the time
where would you find the time i don't
jerk off much no i just well yeah after
18 a day i wouldn't
like you
you need like a month or so
in the trenches dude
yeah yeah she needs a rest saga
uh yeah i think it's it's like you know
what horniness is like the devil of
working hard that's very true
you know it's like it's the one thing
and so like i've all been i've been
about working hard and also like have a
girlfriend but yeah yeah it's like like
i even before i had a girlfriend i just
went like anti-sex mode yeah i was like
i was like shut off sex drive work hard
and i was like just strange that does
happen sometimes i just get in like a
trans for like four or five days where i
don't even think about it yeah yeah and
then like the next three i'll be like i
need a job you're so much more powerful
yeah if you don't give in
you reckon yeah because you're actually
just like focused then what if you have
like a wet dream though
i do i do i used to have them so often
i think you were jacking up 18 times a
day no they're going cold turkey i don't
i was like it was like it was like every
month or every two months i would just
bust my pants when i slept
it happened during the summerathon
you haven't during the show yeah did it
actually because i didn't jerk off at
all during the subathon and i didn't
hook up with my girlfriend because you
know we didn't have sex
yeah i'm alive every minute how's it
happen like once just once was it cool
was it um i did definitely i was live
the whole time i mean like you're
wearing it wasn't like caught like
[ __ ] you know shamu drops down and a
wave comes up yeah it's not what you
want
i just i just woke up and i was like
and then i went to the bathroom and i
hobbled over and i was like that's funny
and then i told stream like three weeks
after the seventh ended
just enough to let the shame and you get
it yes yeah right because i didn't want
to tell them that morning because i was
like this is too close to the right i
think you wouldn't be the end of it
right yeah yeah
but yeah that that happens doesn't
happen as much anymore but wow like my
current roommate slime who's the guy who
got me into streaming i slept over his
house and we're going to smash
tournament the next day and i woke up
just [ __ ] trousers full
and i had to go to him and i'd be like i
look i'm coming to you on the day of
your daughter's wedding for some
underwear
and he was like yeah that's right
oh my god
but i have then you unlock the power of
work
yeah i mean yeah i uh definitely feel
like less drive to when i'm when i'm
hardly working yeah
i don't know it gets to a point where
there's a build up right and then if you
you try to concentrate on work and then
for some reason like you you just carve
on your shoulder yeah got a devil on
your shoulders
yeah the devil in your soul is just like
come
right now
no one will be as bad as sodapop and you
hear he's an insane man
because he will be on stream he used to
do this back in the day more so but he'd
just be on stream and then be like good
morning i'm gonna go jerk off and he'd
just leave his stream on and he would
leave for like five minutes come back
and be like all right what are we doing
today and like like shamelessly what on
a consistent basis there are still many
clips you can find of this and i was
like to have that lack of shame would be
so impressive isn't there a clip of him
[ __ ] himself as well
i mean that's just art yeah that's
dedication at that point i can't just
it's shocked
how could you just not wait till the
stream's over yeah no just sorry what's
what happened
i just [ __ ] himself on stage you just
[ __ ] himself on stream i think it was
like a fart and it just came and then he
made a shot he immediately was just like
he shouted himself
guys i mean was the last time you shoot
yourself
high school yeah really
much much younger middle school probably
dude about some scares yeah yeah first
like three months i was dating cutie i
[ __ ] myself in front of her it was so
sad how did that happen
what happened i just became horribly ill
and i was staying at her place
and i was just [ __ ] myself
constantly but it was like a new
relationship how you know she's she's
there yeah yeah that's
but still it's not great to [ __ ] in
front of her and have [ __ ] underwear and
be like and be like a poopy
stinky
but she was very cool about it how did
you explain it you really were just like
i just had to suck it up and be like
i [ __ ] myself
i said it coolly though
as coolly as you could it's like damn
[ __ ] myself my babe
[ __ ] myself you look down there there
might be some [ __ ] for you
and she's like oh there is a vile
creature
speaking you are sick so that that
doesn't count yeah well it's like
[ __ ] yourself not being sick i mean
i have no [ __ ] that's negligence
yeah if you [ __ ] yourself not sick you
are negligent and you are not taking
good care of yourself you either drink
way too much or you are just not get
those shits when i've drank too much no
i don't yeah it depends it's it's
the next morning right no no you don't
no no i don't no i'm five percent welsh
so i never put myself
[Music]
time you drink you get the shits
afterwards yeah in the morning i'm like
immediately i'm just i think oh i feel
horrible i think me too yeah and it's
not it's never a pretty one no it's
never a pretty one just some white
clover it fixes everything you also can
root boot and loot in australia
do you know that one what
what does that mean
you you you
so you [ __ ] root so you [ __ ] yeah
and then you boot you throw up and then
you steal whoever your [ __ ] stings
and then you leave
it's the root boot and loot who told you
yeah australian i know i mean i i
haven't heard it personally but i
believe it do you know what a meat
uh
hold up
do you know what a meat lottery is
i
thought yeah yeah in australia they'll
have lotteries where the town comes
together and you can win a bunch of meat
and you can just buy little vouchers to
win the meat that's that's in like kind
of small countries yeah when you said
meat lottery i was thinking something
like meat spin like around there yeah
they turn the lights off they play who's
in my mouth yeah yeah that's right you
get
is that a dildo
it's like the try next youtube trend
yeah
is it a dildo or a dick no yeah yeah
that's a youtube video yeah yeah that is
a youtube video why would it be like a
screen right and you would just see the
dudes like head and torso yeah and
there'd be a screen and then someone
would put something in his butt yeah and
they'd be like you have to guess
and then the guy's like no that's
definitely a dildo that's a dildo and
then you go to the next one and he goes
no this one's the dildo
was he you had to be 100 right right
i didn't watch enough oh come on i just
saw the title and i was like wow no
mills know me yeah yeah
actually i couldn't believe it was on
youtube yeah it is crazy you can just
look up like nude yoga and then
immediately you hit get hit with
thumbnails it's just coochie yeah
yeah it's wild how youtube decides to uh
there's just lessons in there it's tight
i think because the alternative is like
you're on twitch and then you're
constantly scared of like like a nipple
flash your butt flash and you're like
i'm gonna get banned but on youtube it's
like we'll just hit you with this yellow
button yeah yeah and that's it you don't
get banned so where's your stream of you
watching nude yoga you know it's coming
i would feel terrible i don't want to be
like a child sexual awakening like i
don't think most of my viewers are
children i think they're mostly like
older
but there's a chance
they're all adults
there's not a single kid in my audience
there's only adults who watch me come on
guys they're all mature uh but there's
definitely a kid and you have like a
weird sexual awakening and i don't want
to be there for it
that's all i'm saying
is like thank you if you didn't watch
that nude yoga yeah i didn't tune into
that stream i wouldn't have met my
girlfriend yeah no i don't want to hear
this
brother
oh my god i'm hungry bears though you
guys want to get dead so hungry yeah
yeah let's join i guess enough of this a
tea if you wouldn't mind a t yeah you
want tea after this i'm taking some tea
after this shut the [ __ ] up don't mock
my clients i'm sorry i'm trying i'm so
frustrated
that's that's northern man that's all
northern we say dinner like normal
people in the south
yo that ain't my man that ain't my pants
you've heard my taste you know what i've
enjoyed i really like
things with mysteries like i've like
erased parasite you like to race i like
to race yeah i did like even off the
scene
yeah i had no problems with it
you know what i'm i think i'm a guy i
don't give a [ __ ] about the ending like
i'm okay with the bad
i'm okay with a bad ending if the
journey was good it does okay i i do
agree with that in some senses but a
race journey wasn't even that good
i think it was like it's not my favorite
but i think it was good i enjoyed it it
was not a waste of my time but a race
was one of those shows where like the
ending was so bad
but but the ending was also like
necessary for it to be good yeah you
know what i mean
yeah like game of thrones you know it
was a shitty ending but we had a good
time it's still you know what they just
did a study it's still super popular
it's one of the most popular tv shows
still it's still a great show like first
five seasons are a great tv yeah and
like i think people are so focused on
the ending and it's not like i think
code yes is a better ending in death
note but there's no shot that it's
better than death note even if the
ending's like beautiful and succinct or
whatever people people love code girls
yeah they do even though the first 10
episodes suck but they think that what
the first 10 episodes talk
yeah they're terrible i don't think they
suck i feel like the pacing is bad
enough to turn people away right code
geass or death note it could yes
i thought the first ten episodes were
like the good parts yeah i thought i
thought it was like the second season
when i got [ __ ] here i feel like code
yes there'd be an episode where it's
just like today we are going to find a
cat
and then the next one okay yeah that was
that was actually gonna be like is that
in the first ten i thought that was like
it might be at the end
no it's pretty early is it it might be
but all like first
is in the first like half of code yes
you'll have an episode that covers three
months and then you'll have an episode
that covers like a day at school and
it's really hard to watch and understand
what's going on i think oh the
stallmaster the sixth episode yeah you
are right yeah i'll give you there
that's that's just that's just like
selective memory online that is a
mid-episode yeah yeah but but it's also
just like it i think it's building to
something and it takes a while to get
there but it's still a great show that's
all to say that those are the shows i
like i think you have a good taste
though
yeah
yeah well okay the the thing you gotta
sort that for me like [ __ ] out there
i'll watch it again i'll try it yeah i
mean the thing is talking to you i'm
just like damn this guy just doesn't
like shonen and that's fine or do you
like shonen i like it like i've watched
i watch full metal alchemist you say
it's okay or excuse me i watched my hero
academy is what i meant to say yeah i
like it it was all right i stopped
watching when girl was sucking him and
he punched a guy really hard
it was like the season two finale the
girl was clinging on to him in a
piggyback ride and sucking him dry
[Music]
i'm so weak yeah that was chill and then
i it ended and i was like i will never
need to watch a show again
it's offered me everything i can it was
it was it was really kind of the third
season was really [ __ ] i'm trying to
watch all one piece right now oh i'm
reading watch it or read it i will read
it yeah
reading it is a lot more manageable than
watching it i don't know how people
watch one piece nowadays also the anime
just sucks
yeah yeah a lot like this
i've heard the research
the reason is really really good what
are you gonna do [ __ ] flop between
the manga and anime at will like some
kind of psychopath that's what i tried
to do you can't do that i do that all
the time yeah yeah for like a fight for
a fight scene okay okay some sometimes
there are moments like i prefer watching
anime right there's never going to be a
moment in manga that is going to hit as
hard as that same moment being done well
in anime because you've got the music
you've got the voice acting sound
effects the sound effects like to me
like i'm not saying anime is the
superior medium i'm saying that like i
get way more immersed
watching anime if it's done right yeah
because there's so many examples where
anime isn't done right i've i've not
read as much mongers as you guys but
definitely the uh
turn on that panel turn the page sorry
and vinlon saga with the ascolad thing
at the end yeah yeah yeah spoiler
warning was like better than the anime
for me well that's because
like i feel like it's hard to judge
because but in the anime they got the
music building up to it yeah yeah all
the signs in the manga you're just like
but now what the [ __ ] moment is what
makes it so good yeah
total aside but he just fights a sumo
wrestler okay cool and uh did you know
that part yeah i watched the anime
outfit it's it's the worst animation
ever
the crowd is perfectly still but they
have like the wind effect over it and
they're all like this and it's like and
their hair should be like this and
shaking but it's like nothing's
happening they're just still
and it's like it's like 80 seconds of
reaction shots right and i'm like god
you are the biggest in the world and
this is what you offer
it's so sad i i just want to milk it
yeah i mean just cause it's popular and
uh big doesn't mean it's gonna be good
right i mean look at [ __ ] seven
deadly since season three yeah well i
think the problem with the one piece
anime is that it just never takes a
break at least with things like my hero
academia jutsu kaisen all that stuff you
come in it comes in seasons right one
piece has just been airing since 1998
which is [ __ ] insane yeah so like of
course the pacing is going to be [ __ ]
but i wish they did do seasons of one
piece they just took some [ __ ] breaks
yeah yeah yeah exactly it's okay the
money the money the money
yeah well which is apparently not not
enough uh [ __ ] uh problems neverland
um
that's true that's true yeah well anyway
that's been this anime talk for trash
taste we talk about a lot of animals
yeah we do probably like the most in any
guest episode more than prose d i always
talk about a lot of proteins oh yeah
that's true that's really easy
pull outs
coming on man yeah thank you very much
for coming on hey look at all these
patrons though yeah pick your favorite
patron pick your friends right now
on screen whoa
yeah wow look at that piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hey if you'd like to support the show go
to our patreon patreon.com also follow
us on twitter send us your memes on the
subreddit and if you hate our face
listen to us on spotify and uh yeah go
check out odd stuff yeah anything i want
to shout out
yeah he has a podcast as well yeah yeah
you can find it if you want
live your life
bye
[Music]
you